testing one two testing this meeting
foreign
good morning everybody Welcome to the
Tuesday March 7th hearing of the science
technology and energy committee we have
two public hearings today
one on House Bill 609 relative to energy
facility citing the other is House Bill
142 relative to the operation of the
Burgess biopower plant as usual we we
will begin our meeting this morning by
all rising and joining Rebecca
so it's a packed agenda for this morning
we have received as of this moment 20
pink cards
for people who want to testify in House
Bill 609 so at this point I'm going to
turn the gavel over to my vice chair
representative Douglas Thomas to preside
over the meeting for uh my testimony to
foreign
thank you chairman Bose
please step up to the mic and
present
for the record I'm representative
Michael those
I represent
Rockingham District Five the town of
Epping
five-term state legislator who is chair
of this committee and I'm here this
morning to introduce House Bill 609
a reform of the site evaluation
committee
in House Bill 2 in 2021 and Senate Bill
this legislative body convened two study
committees to study the site evaluation
committee and its operation
now the site evaluation committee has
been around for a long time over 20
years it has been reformed several times
during the course of that 20 years
and those reforms while they have helped
they have
continued to produce
limited results from the site evaluation
committee
the study committees that I sat on
in 2021 and 2022
provided almost unanimous testimony
that the site Opera the site evaluation
committee operation was slow
there were very few people who testified
that the process worked well everybody
had issues with the way the site
so the study committees both determined
both filed reports which you can view on
the general court website on the House
website
both those reports indicated that
additional reforms
would likely be needed
to streamline the operation of the site
evaluation committee
the result of the second of those two
reports Senate Bill 256 study committee
report is House Bill 609 which you see
now I'll be talking about this bill
this morning in general terms
I have passed out to everyone on the
committee
2023-0769 H
which is
an amendment that I will be proposing
as is usually the case with
large bills of this sort
when you introduce the bill in
November
you get a lot of response and a lot of
feedback on it
and
I have Incorporated that response and
feedback into the amendment
that we will
obviously we'll have
quite a few days
in the interim to reflect on
the amendment itself
but if you have specific questions for
me this morning
I will answer them by using the language
in the amendment rather than the
language in the introduced version of
the bill
but before we get to that let's talk in
general terms about
why
this bill has even been introduced to
you've all heard the saying that time is
money
in the business world that's certainly
true
when a energy project gets proposed
and needs to be cited and approved
the longer time it takes to get that
project approved the more costly it will
be
and those costs are typically passed on
to those of us who will eventually
enjoy the rewards of the
so it's imperative that the site
evaluation process
be done in as efficient a manner as
possible to keep its costs as low as
possible
now the previous site evaluation
committee legislation the existing
has a lot of excellent
process
information in it
so as a result
what we did was we essentially moved the
site evaluation committee process
from a separate committee
into the responsibilities of the Public
Utilities Commission
but that move was made by essentially
copying RSA 162h
into a new chapter that will appear
under
the
duties and operations
statutes for the Public Utilities
Commission that new chapter will be
if you were to sit down with RSA 162-h
and
and read them side by side what you
would discover is that
their practically identical they're very
the reason for that is that the
processes that have been developed over
the years in 162-h were good processes
for the most part
and so all those good processes were
preserved
the one thing that wasn't working
particularly well for this site
evaluation committee was the fact that
it was a separate
part-time committee
that was comprised of a lot of different
members
who had a difficult time
that's the root of the inefficiency of
the site evaluation process as it exists
today
and some folks who will testify after me
of course the site evaluation process
also has
there's a lack of institutional
knowledge because of the turnover of the
site evaluation committee and its
existing form
there's sparse technical expertise
there are jurisdictional ambiguities in
the existing law
there's a lack of funding
and a lack of dedicated support staff
there's a lack of definition of the role
of the public Council and the
administrator
there's weak enforcement of
these are some of the issues that hb609
one of the big objections that
have surfaced since the introduction of
this bill
has been
the idea that somehow hb609
shuts off or reduces public input into
but if you look closely at the sections
of the statute
that exists today
and examine those side by side
with what's in House Bill 609 you
the same amount of input that the public
has today to a site evaluation project
will be available under hb609
the only difference will be that instead
of a separate nine-member committee
making final decisions about the
viability of a project
those decisions will be made by the
professional staff at the Public
Utilities Commission
the professional staff at the puc
knows regulatory processes they've been
doing this for decades
they have a well-established process
they have
three full-time Commissioners and
full-time staff on board to support
the work and the activity of the
commission
moving the site evaluation process from
a separate committee
to the Public Utilities Commission
will professionalize the site evaluation
process
it will make it more timely more
efficient
and over time the accumulated
institutional knowledge of the
commission and its staff
will be able to streamline the process
to the point
that energy citing projects
we'll move through the process much more
now as I indicated when I opened this
meeting there's over 20 people who
signed up to speak on this issue
so I'm going to
wrap up my testimony
here so that other people can have a
chance to weigh in with their opinions
on this legislation
and of course I'll be happy to take
questions before I turn the floor over
to other speakers
thank you chairman Vose
do I see any questions I do uh
representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question chairman Vose
I actually did compare
hb609 and RSA 162-h side by side and I
highlighted where they differ and one
place that I noticed they differ is that
the current statute mentions renewable
energy in a few places and hb609 at
least the version that I read last night
does not in fact the word renewable does
not appear anywhere in there and I'm
wondering if you can speak to that
please
yes the energy sighting process should
be technology neutral
it's not about deciding that this
technology should be cited versus that
technology should not be cited it's
about deciding
how
whatever technology is proposed should
be cited
so any unnecessary references to
renewable technology were removed in the
rewrite
well
although I do notice that in in the in
the bill it does mention certain
Technologies in particular with
application fees and again renewable is
um I don't believe that's true
I know in the
if you go to page eight
application fees being twelve hundred
dollars per megawatt for the first 40
megawatts eighteen hundred dollars per
megawatt for each megawatt in excessive
40 megawatts for wind energy and solar
energy systems
amen
so this would be an the amendment hb609
that I passed out earlier page eight
lines
six and seven
uh representative Thomas Winnie Thomas
thank you uh
Douglas Thomas
um as long as we're talking about those
fees on page eight whether it's in the
original bill or the amendment are you
suggesting now that Doe grabs all of
these fees do they go directly to doe
with this bill now
section
and I'm sorry are you referring to the
amendment or 609 yes I'm always going to
refer to the amendment even though we
if you look at page 13 line 34
363 D colon 18 fund established
there is hereby established in the
Office of the State Treasurer or
non-lapsing special fund to be known as
the energy facility sighting fund
all application fees and other filing
fees received by the commission under
d10 shall be deposited in the fund all
monies in the fund shall be continually
appropriated to the department offset
operating costs of the department or
commission arising from this chapter Etc
so that is where the money goes
follow-up yes so essentially it's in a
fund in the treasurer's office but the
doe has complete access to it is that
correct
yes the commission and the department
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
um I was looking at the makeup of the
current uh SEC and noticed that there
are representatives from the Department
of Business and economic Affairs the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources department of transportation
these all seem like important voices to
consider and and have
as part of the decision-making Authority
for project citing will
will they also be incorporated in this
new SEC or how will we ensure that those
points of view are
given a seat at the table with decision
making capacity
thank you for the question it's a good
one so
there's two different components here
that you have to consider one is people
who provide information to the decision
makers the other is the decision makers
the Departments that you mentioned
which will no longer be part of the
decision-making body
are still important people to provide
information as interveners or other
participants in the adjudicative process
that will result
from the passage of hb609
the only difference is
the final adjudication will be made by
the three members of the commission
not by members of a much larger body
with Lexus less expertise
and less time to devote to uh
analyzing
the issues involved in the whole
I'll take well one more question from
someone who hasn't asked it yet before I
asked mine representative Noel
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question in moving the site
evaluation committee to the Department
of energy does the department of energy
gain any adjudicatory responsibilities
in that move or is that all handled by
the puc
thank you for the question it's all
handled by the puc the does role here
will be administrative and they will
play an important role in
compliance with the terms of an issued
certificate
and complaint resolution complaint
investigation and resolution that's the
role that the department will play
and the commission will handle all
adjudicative legal issues okay thank you
okay we have a lot of speakers here I
will ask one more question I will ask a
question that you certainly may defer to
to some of the upcoming parties if you
wish but my question is uh I have heard
that
investors for energy projects
particularly those that would be
receiving the new funding from the
federal government with the
infrastructure Bill uh are could be
shying away from the state and some of
the monies that are being currently
fished out to other states are because
they have a much faster uh
citing process and they look at New
Hampshire as being very slow in
cumbersome
can thus they're not coming here and
we're not getting the money for it can
my comment would simply be and thank you
for the question that
everybody who testified before the
site evaluation study committees
indicated that the process is too slow
to too cumbersome too inefficient
if that results in us getting fewer
federal dollars
then we need to fix that and that's what
hb609 will do
so thank you for that question thank you
senior representative McWilliams did
have a question well I'm sorry go ahead
Nick Williams
uh thank you chair and chair
um
so right now the Public Utilities
Commission has a full docket and is
often running months sometimes years
behind on some decisions how would they
fit this site evaluation committee time
requirement into their already busy
schedule
so the chair of the Public Utilities
Commission testified before our study
committee the two SB 256 study committee
and he assured us that the commission's
schedule and workload could accommodate
the site evaluation committee work there
is a provision in the legislation or the
amendment that I handed out earlier to
augment
the support staff for the commission and
the department to handle the the tasks
required by House Bill 609
thank you okay thank you chairman Vose I
think we will move on now to our next
speaker uh is Mr Drew Beamer from the
SEC
chairman please turn on the microphone
there we go
chairman Vos and members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to be here today and give input on House
Bill 609 regarding SEC reform
unfortunately commissioner goldner is
unable to attend as he is an apuc
hearing at the moment
I would also like to thank the SEC study
committee whose diligent work has taken
a complex issue
and distilled it into a more clear and
concise legislative proposal
while I have faith in the legislature to
determine the specifics of the process
moving forward I am quite adamant that
whatever process we employ should be
very clear upfront and transparent
uncertainty in the permitting phase
elicits hesitance in developers which in
turn has slowed down new proposals
particularly renewable generation in the
state
accordingly other states and regions are
benefiting disproportionately from
incentives set aside for grid
modernization and renewable energy
development
the process can be easy or hard long or
short however the complexity or duration
of permitting
while important is not the main
strategic choke point
the main roadblock is uncertainty in the
process itself
uncertainty which I am confident this
bill can and will sufficiently address
we must also ensure that we give due
weight to public input
and that all stakeholders are afforded
their rightful place at the table
finally we should Endeavor to make this
process more resilient
the choices made here will impact future
administrators staff and puc
Commissioners and while I am personally
a staunch Defender
of legislative intent
I believe that guard rails are essential
to ensure that that intent
your intent
endures through subsequent
Administrations
I believe this bill sufficiently
addresses these issues and I'm happy to
support it on behalf of myself the SEC
and commissioner Dan goldner
thank you and I look forward to your
questions
thank you for your testimony questions
from the committee representative Wendy
Thomas has a question thank you Mr chair
um I'm going to speak to the original
bill because we have not accepted the
amendment yet on page eight where we
talk about the fees again can you
explain to me why the price per megawatt
for any kind of renewable is 10 times
that of any for uh any non-renewable
I am looking at page eight
starting at line six twelve hundred for
megawatts these are fees uh for wind
energy and
the amendment also includes solar but um
for any wind energy system
um at present I believe there was no
additional per megawatt fee for solar
generation there's just an upfront
application fee of sixty thousand
dollars no my question is I'm sorry my
question is why is that twelve hundred
dollars per megawatt however it's 120
per megawatt for natural gas oh um it's
I believe it is 1200 per megawatt for
the first 40 megawatts of any generation
okay so I'm just I'm just curious can
you explain why there's such a price
I can explain that under currently
constructed there's usually an incentive
to charge renewable generation sources
less for instance the price for nuclear
I know is higher the price for wind is
lower and
um
but I do not have an answer as to why
this particular fee structure was
constructed this way thank you I
apologize
further questions for Mr Beamer from the
committee
representative Doug Thomas
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
under this bill and potentially under
the amendment should be adopted
is there any difference at all in your
mind as to either the influence or the
number of public
inputs that would be able to be put
before the SEC for any project
I believe the public input would remain
the same there are multiple Avenues by
which to express public input the first
and most convenient of which is directly
communicating with myself the
administrator we process a presently not
high but certainly can be high
amount of comments public exhibits
public testimonies that are submitted in
advance of public hearings as to give
the committee members and subcommittee
members sufficient time to actually read
them before the hearing begins
um normally what I will do is impose an
administrative deadline on submission of
testimony and Exhibits of about one week
before hearing the reason for doing that
is I want to make sure that all the
committee members have an opportunity to
read all the comments and all the um
exhibits that will be presented then at
the actual hearing itself
it is a pub leaves these are all public
deliberations and the members of the
public have and will continue to have
the opportunity to participate
um through either
um
statuses interveners or just status as
follow-up
thank you Mr thank you for the follow-up
so would
assuming that we uh adopt the amendment
uh in this bill as well would this
process be any better or the same as
most other States's citing processes I
would bring us closer to congruent with
other states citing processes that's for
sure one of the main things that's
different about our process is the SEC
has currently constructed includes
multiple
um commissioners of different
departments
and also multiple public members the
issue with the commissioners of the
Departments while well intended
certainly to have diversity of opinion
um it manifests itself in those folks
who have full-time jobs are unable to
attend so they appoint designees so
really the site evaluation committee
oftentimes is comprised of designees of
Commissioners and then in the instance
of the public members I have had times
when I've needed to get a public member
to establish a quorum and they were
unreachable for whatever reason because
they have their own life or it was you
know over the holidays or they were on
vacation
um so the the main thing
um with me at this point in time that I
believe this bill fixes
is that it makes the adjudicative
process a lot more simple by shepherding
these sorts of issues to a panel the the
puc of people who were specifically
nominated and confirmed based on their
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh having served on a
large number of uh site evaluation
committees in the past one of the
reoccurring problems that was never
really able to address well is
post-construction or post issuing of a
permit where problems arose there was a
number of various places where buildings
were put where they weren't supposed to
and so forth and so on does this
adequately now address so that there's a
follow-up a place where people can come
to and say I'm having a problem with the
way it's being built I don't think
they're following their permit or even
the permit D that has to come back and
say we found something we didn't expect
we need to amend a permit does this
adequately address those issues I
believe so because the current follow-up
and enforcement of compliance is
difficult under the current construction
because what it entails is it entails um
basically me to investigate or appoint
somebody as a proxy on be on my behalf
so we'll convene a sub committee for the
issue the subcommittee will say we're
either going to hire a firm to
investigate or going to find the
appropriate person in state government
to investigate based on resources
available under the new legislation I
believe what would happen is all of that
investigative stuff and enforcement of
compliance would be sent over to the doe
and the doe has sufficient staff
resources and subject matter expertise
to to adjudicate and investigate these
complaints in a more timely manner then
representative McWilliams has a question
sure
um
work when you're when you're looking at
an applicant how do you determine that
their financials are sufficient
for financing of the project yes that's
an excellent question I
I don't I don't know that there
presently is a
system to determine the financial health
of the applicant
okay if that's if that was the question
yeah I mean I I there's a way to
determine how many fees they have to pay
the state of New Hampshire
um no whether they're capable of
actually producing the project oh well
you know a lot of those things
um will come out during the SEC process
there was um you know there are
different phases to the application
process and you know as was demonstrated
in um the most recent very large project
there was the Northern Pass project
obviously is a lot of these things will
come up over the course of the
permitting phase through uh the site
evaluation committee itself asking
specific questions to that effect
follow-up follow-up so just to
understand this I know in the past we've
had applicants who had incomplete
applications and that tends to drag the
process on and on is there anything
under this new proposal that would
require a complete applicant in order to
move to the next steps
I believe that you do in fact have to
have a complete application to move
forward under the new proposal that's my
understanding thank you
and your your concern is warranted that
has happened multiple times
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um you just stated that the doe has the
staff to adjudicate
um however every time we hear a bill
that changes anything we hear from the
doe that they need to hire new staff to
accomplish it the fiscal note has not
been introduced even though the last
we've heard was January 10th are you
confident that the doe has the staff to
adjudicate these I am personally
confident but that question may better
be directed to a doe representative a
little later on thank you
okay I'd remind members that we have
over 20 pink cards to get through so
try to aim your questions very
specifically at someone who can answer
them
and I want to thank you Mr Beamer for
your testimony thank you and I'd like
the next call on Mr Chris Elms and Mr
David chulock from the Department of
energy
good morning gentlemen
don't forget to turn on the mic good
morning and uh yeah I think you know I
can talk fast so I'll try to try to do
so uh for the record my name is Chris
Elms I'm the Deputy Commissioner of the
New Hampshire Department of energy I'm
joined uh by David schulock who's the
general counsel uh at the department uh
we want to thank you for the opportunity
to testify this morning uh in support of
House Bill 609 we are happy to join our
colleagues from the office of the
consumer Advocate from the puc and the
SEC and the Department of Environmental
Services and supporting the bill
uh you know currently the department has
very little statutory responsibility
related to the citing process however uh
given the fact that New Hampshire has
energy needs that we have to meet while
minimizing impacts the ability to have
an effective citing process is of keen
interest to us
we talked about a citing in the 10-year
State energy strategy
which states that delivering appropriate
energy infrastructure requires
predictability defined processes good
communication and clear standards for
achievement you know I I think others
you've heard from representative Vos
from from Mr Beamer you'll hear from
others on some of
you know those inefficiencies and
challenges that are apparent in the
current process you know it's clear to
me based on some of the stakeholder
input we've heard over the last few
study committees through
um you know public hearings we've had on
other pieces of legislation that we we
are not achieving those goals now uh and
and that we have an opportunity with
this bill to to improve our process
we've now participated in in two
separate study committees and I think
David here has attended just about every
meeting
um we've had a wealth of feedback from
interest from interested stakeholders in
the public and that's reflected in house
bill 609. this is a bipartisan bill and
it's a result of that input and that
collaboration it's a common sense reform
this bill is not picking any side it's
just saying that regardless of what
technology or fuel type or whatever we
need the citing process to be effective
in determining whether or not a project
is right for New Hampshire
so look at the end of the day this bill
is not really a radical
departure from the current system most
of the existing statute is transferred
over is updated to new venues in state
government but it preserves many of the
the various citing requirements and and
public inputs
um and and in some cases you know
strengthens the ability for the public
to be confident that their voice is
being heard
these reforms are likely to add
substantial administrative efficiencies
making the process more professional
making the jurisdictions more clear
um you know through the clarified role
of the state agencies through the
greater consistency of the knowledgeable
of knowledgeable membership uh of the
Public Utilities Commission and you know
the ability to ensure that voices are
heard applicants will have a much more
predictable sense of the likelihood of
success of their application or a much
more predictable sense of what
conditions and standards they're going
to have to meet in order to make sure
that their project is right for New
Hampshire
with all the federal money that's that's
the the spending that's um come through
and with you know Technologies
um becoming more viable becoming more
cost effective
you know and frankly with some of the
challenges that we're facing when it
comes to reliability and resource
adequacy we are facing a real
opportunity to make sure that we have
resources that are able to come into New
Hampshire and that we're not squandering
those those uh opportunities to have
more cost-effective resources
um to have better and more viable
resources
by having a citing process that's not
getting the job done we have to get it
right this bill is not saying that the
answer will always be yes it's not
saying that the answer will always be no
it's saying that the path the process to
get to that answer is clear consistent
and right for New Hampshire we look
forward to being part of the process
happy to answer any questions David will
probably take uh many of them because
he's uh he's better equipped to do so
representative Mick Williams has a
question
um you talked about streamlining the
process can you just explain to me what
a
streamlined process timeline looks like
is there a certain length that you're
shooting for what what is that
the timelines remain the same in the
statute in terms of
deadlines for completion I think the
thought is that the Public Utilities
Commission is
perhaps better able to manage a docket
and and get things to progress than the
site evaluation committee might have
been able to do in part because there
would be fewer members a fewer people
sitting on a decision uh they'd only
have to gather two at the at the least
instead of seven
so follow-up follow-up
um so so in terms of the participation
you only need two people in order to
progress and make a decision from any of
the checkpoints in the process but I
guess my question is are you targeting
to get through a site evaluation
analysis in a certain period of time are
you trying to do this in under a year
and under six months is is there
something that streamlines it compared
to historical SEC process no the
timelines
the statutory timelines I believe remain
the same so the statute does not do that
the thought is that the puc would be
able to streamline the process because
it knows how to to run a docket and to
okay I'm having trouble
just understanding that since the puc
has had issues representative McWilliams
um right
she asked to follow up do you know
what the timeline might look like it is
it is it a year
representative Doug Thomas has a
clarification question also and yeah
just to be clear you know we we
currently don't oversee the citing
process so we're you know we'll have the
timelines here but um I think David has
has that now
so this is from it's in the current
statute it makes its way all the way
into the Amendments uh within 365 days
of accepting the application the
commission shall issue or deny the
certificate
representative Doug Thomas thank you Mr
thank you I I I believe if for my
understanding uh based on representative
mcwilliam's question uh the the
timelines are the same but if I heard
you correctly what you're really saying
is that this new bill and and
potentially the amendment would better
ensure that those timelines are met
versus going over them like certain
projects have done before in the past is
yeah that's certainly part of it and and
streamline might not be the perfect word
for what it is there are also you know
those administrative efficiencies come
in the form of
you know the funding and the work of the
site evaluation process is is kind of
what people call Lumpy uh you know there
are times where it's
um very busy and there are times where
it's it's not busy and obviously you
know funding that goes along with that
under the current process is also lumpy
so you know um by incorporating the the
parts of the citing process into the
Public Utilities Commission into the
site of into the department of energy
um there are opportunities to you know
leverage other resources at the
department at the commission to
help smooth out some of that work so
that if if there are opportunities where
where we need to find uh you know more
things to do on on those those uh times
where there is not a lot of citing work
well then now the commission has that
resource to do so and likewise when the
when the work is
is more uh than it normally is
um being part of the larger whole gives
that opportunity to leverage resources
from from the entities that they're a
part of
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I actually want to
ask you the same question that
representative Wendy Thomas asked Mr
Beamer uh why is it that the application
fee for Renewables is so much higher
than for other types of energy and I'll
let David address that I do think that
that's being preserved from existing
statute
um that that is preserved from existing
statute except that in the the most
recent Amendment there is an additional
charge for solar that did not exist
before
it's my understanding that those fees
were designed to generate the the
income necessary for the site evaluation
committee to conduct a docket for that
type of generation so for instance
you'll if you'll see that the cost for
say an oil facility is much less per
megawatt hour and that's because you
don't hit some of the same issues
they're not necessarily as complicated
and then secondly
those facilities tend to be much much
larger so you don't have to charge as
much per megawatt hour to generate
enough
funds for the site evaluation committee
to conduct its work
if that makes sense to you yeah
representative creation has a question
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
um I get so accepting the premise that
the SEC has currently constituted is is
too inefficient to do its job and we
need to bring this function into the
state government
um
I guess why is doe the right home for
deciding citing of energy projects like
I understand
that the doe obviously has
um a lot of important input into how
much energy we need and and things like
that but in my
mental model
um citing site evaluation is more about
the environmental impacts more about the
sort of cultural impacts impacts on
communities so why why doe instead of
Des or another agency sure and I'll just
say under this proposal thank you for
the question because it's it's important
to clarify uh under this proposal it
would be the Public Utilities Commission
who would be making those decisions and
the department of energy and other
departments other stakeholders would
have the opportunity to intervene in
those dockets and and let our voices be
heard for whatever issues are important
to us the department of Energy's role
here would really be on the tail end of
things with the ongoing sort of
monitoring and compliance with with the
certificate that gets put out we are
pretty well situated to do so we have a
division of enforcement we have staff
who who do this type of work on things
like you know our
um our fimza grant which is the pipeline
safety and hazardous materials uh
Administration from the federal
government they do the safety work for
you know pipelines we have our Dig Safe
programs we have folks who know the the
compliance side of things and I think
we're well situated to do that work
um and likewise the Public Utilities
Commission is an adjudicative body that
you know professionally looks at energy
issues I think they're they are well
situated to take in all that input all
of the you know perspectives and
concerns of stakeholders to weigh those
things following the criteria that have
been laid out by this bill and in
previous pieces of legislation that are
being carried over and and to render a
decision so uh I said a lot there I
don't know David if if I missed anything
I think you covered it okay
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um we heard from the previous testifier
from SEC that he felt that Doe had the
current staff to absorb this change can
you say with confidence that Doe has the
current staff to absorb this change
sure and and to that sort of earlier
question I know there are times where
there are pieces of legislation where we
do raise
hey we would need staff to be able to
achieve this we would need you know
Revenue whatever it is and you know the
way our department is is
broken up right there are a number of
Divisions you know four divisions with a
varied set of responsibilities so I'm
talking about this specific yeah yeah
and I apologize I'll get there but we
can't really just plug and play
um
you know any employee anywhere I think
for this task we we do have the
capabilities and the know-how to get um
what we need to do I think the bill does
give us the ability to have the revenue
to fund those positions so
um and I'm sorry did you say think or
you're confident I I am confident okay I
have a follow-up
follow up
um have you uh has the doe provided any
uh fiscal note information for this
specific Bill uh we that is something I
I know there have been a number of
amendments that have come to us so uh I
don't know if we have sent something in
it seems like we have not so that's
something we can continue to work on yes
thank you
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman um I just want to
take another whack at this question and
and because I haven't heard it really
answered adequately yet Perhaps that
might be because
perhaps the question is is best answered
by the author of the legislation but
going back to the application fees can
you can you offer a reason as to why
the application fee for a solar
or a wind energy facility is 10 times
that of
the fee for a natural gas or biomass
so those
those those fees were designed and are
in the current legislation with the
exception of the additional megawatt fee
for solar facilities and it's my
understanding that those fees were
designed to generate sufficient income
for the SEC to do its work for that type
of generation so solar facilities wind
facilities tend to be quite small in
terms of megawatt hours or megawatts for
the facilities and so the megawatt hour
charge has to be greater to generate a
sufficient income whereas larger
facilities which are the other types of
fuels they tend to be larger the the
megawatt hour charge can be lower in
order to generate the amount of fees
necessary for the work to be completed
okay so it's it's follow-up follow thank
you Mr chairman so it's a function of
the relative scale expected scale of the
type of facilities that are
expected to be seen by the yes that's my
understanding that goes back quite a
number of years but that's that's my
memory of it yeah thank you
representative Christian has another
question yes uh sorry just a follow-up
on that point
um if it is a function of scale then I'm
confused why solar and and wind would
then jump to 1800 per megawatt if those
larger facilities would be
easier to
am I asking this question correctly so
if the justification for the higher fee
per megawatt is that these facilities
are smaller then why would the larger
facilities end up costing more per
megawatt that's confusing to me
the larger facilities tend to pay less
per megawatt
and that generates sufficient income for
sorry I'm asking specifically about
solar and and win so in the statute it's
1200 per megawatt for the first 40 and
then 1800 per megawatt thereafter okay
representative remember we're not here
today we're here to to ask to gather
information I think your question was
asked institutionally
so let's move on uh so you know more
questions from the committee for you two
gentlemen I want to thank you for being
here and testifying now I'd like to call
on the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services and assistant
good morning for the record my name is
Mark Sanborn I'm the assistant
commissioner at the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services I
also want to note for the question
period the commissioner Scott is also
here if there's any interest in
questions for the commissioner he's
happy uh to to address those I know you
have over 20 speakers and a number of
folks have already spoken so
um I when we have a letter of testimony
that a letter of support that the
commissioner signed that I passed around
I'm going to get to the heart of the
reason Des supports on this legislation
the current structure of the SEC
and the inefficiencies in the process
that result of that structure is the
reason Des supports
um reforming the process and coming up
with a structure that creates
predictability not in terms of outcome
but in terms of the process and how
it'll work
and efficiency right now your current
structure you have a group of volunteers
most of whom have no background in
either energy or permitting of any kind
you have so it is difficult for them to
meet never mind come together and make
good decisions you have a staff of one
that doesn't have any budget other than
the budget for that position
and you have no budget for compliancy or
following up on decisions
there also are some things that this
bill corrects that could improve the
overall structure and how those of us
who are have already having permanent
responsibilities participate in the
process which we're also very supportive
of in terms of what this legislation
does the current SEC does not work
it you they can't most of the time they
can't get meetings together
there's a backlog of complaints
there is
um and there is no real movement for all
the folks who
um continuously support the current SEC
there doesn't seem to be any movement to
then okay let's fund the SEC if you like
the current SEC let's give it the staff
it needs to
um to actually function appropriately
as a representative of the department
that we're permitting is a major part of
what we do I can promise you for all
parties involved whether you're
supportive of a certain permit or not
whether you have concerns whether or not
predictability and efficiency in terms
of how the process is going to unfold
and what to expect in terms of who will
be making those decisions and how they
will be making those decisions lead to
better outcomes
so at the heart of why Des supports this
is we have a role in in energy in the
approval of energy infrastructure for
the environmental pieces that go along
with it we're we're proud of the
processes we use for our permitting
while always being open to ways we can
improve them
and
um we want to be part of a process that
cites and improves energy infrastructure
in a way that can be done so all parties
have a voice and and have acknowledge in
a process they can trust and and folks
who are making decisions having the
background and expertise that is needed
to make those decisions from the
perspective of the New Hampshire
Department of Environmental Services
that does not exist in the current
process nor in the current makeup of the
adjudicum body nor in the total lack of
budget or staff to do the follow-up work
for compliancy one other thing I'll note
I'm going to stick I'm going to
stay tight to the and my responses to
those areas that we can answer as as Des
so in terms of the free structure Etc I
won't be able to give you an answer
other than the current fees are based on
the existing
um uh the committee will have to work
with the folks who formed those fee
structures if they really want to know
what went behind creating those fees
with that I'm happy to answer any
questions
thank you for giving us the Department's
perspective on this legislation
questions representative McWilliams has
a question
thank you chair
um so I just want to understand how this
works in terms of the concerns about the
public the member of the public or
participation by the public and concerns
that that would hold up because the
member of the public cannot attend a
meeting
um
but would you would you be open to some
kind of a you know 10 members of the
public who could who could cycle through
or all attend but only have one voice so
the uh with respect to representative
your mischaracterizing I think the
members of the state agencies don't show
up
so it's not the members of the public
not showing up it's that this is a group
of folks who this isn't their core job
all these folks have other
responsibilities and therefore I I don't
mean I love Taylor Caswell so I mean
this very respectfully ba never shows up
has nothing to do with the public makeup
it has to it has to do with the entire
makeup that includes the state agencies
involved
there in every process in every one of
our process there's ample opportunity
for other public input or other state
agencies to have their voice be heard
about a permitting decision that is
being made I am extremely confident that
by making these structural changes the
ability of departments and the public to
have their voice heard be be Heard On
Any Given item in front of the puc will
still exist if anything
um it it'll exist in a little bit
different than it happens in the other
permitting but DS doesn't hold hearings
for every permit if there is opportunity
in every in every case for there to be
public input so I am very confident
there will still be public input and you
will just have a body of folks who this
is part of their primary responsibility
and therefore will be able to more
efficiently and predictably meet
um to be in order for this and and just
one additional thing to your earlier
question the streamlining isn't in
changing the process per se the
streamlining of this bill is reforming
the structure so that it can it has the
membership and staff who are dedicated
to these activities evolving site the
sighting of energy infrastructure
follow-up question follow-up so just to
we're talking about three puc
Commissioners as the site evaluation
committee that's it and only two
actually need to attend in order to move
forward on any decision that's the
proposal so I'm asking if we can change
that makeup and add a couple more to get
a little bit of variety here because the
puc is all appointees and it doesn't all
it doesn't necessarily reflect the
interests of everyone in this room
so I'm looking at uh the proposal for
having the Attorney General appoint
somebody to be a member or be involved
perhaps that person could have a voting
Authority so that there's at least
something beyond the puc right I hear
what you're saying about attendance and
perhaps different departments don't have
the same interest and it's not a
priority or they don't feel that they
get enough money to compensate people to
attend these all of those are legitimate
concerns but fundamentally we want to
have a site evaluation committee that is
neutral that is independent and so the
concern is making sure that we have the
bodies there that are voting who
represent those interests to be neutral
and independent and I'm not convinced
that three puc Commissioners are truly
neutral and independent because there
are pointees so what I'm looking at is
would you be open to an amendment or
changes to you know get more members on
that board we're going from seven to
three
um respectfully no I I that's the whole
problem
um more voices are only beneficial if
more voices improve the process in this
case
um
the key to a good permitting
and or approving a Distributive process
is ensuring all voices have the
opportunity to speak to the
um to the item to the issue to the
project in question not if that not that
a board or an individual whoever is
approving it are made up of all those
voices
um
I would it's to me it's not important
the number of folks who make up the
adjudicive body it's do the folks on
that board have the expertise in terms
of energy and permitting to
okay representative Carmen has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question
assuming that these these uh facilities
have environmental impacts
why is des willing to actually cut
itself out of the decision procedure and
we're not but but that's not this it's
only the puc that means this bill
doesn't do that if there's a Wetlands
permit required for a project to move
forward there will still be a Wetlands
fraud a permit obtained if there is an
alteration of terrain permit required
for a project the project will still
um obtain an aot permit they will be
attached to the certificate so the
permit will go through our process and
once approved it'll be attached to the
certificate thereby noting that the
environmental approvals needed
improvements needed to obtain a project
have gone forward so so we are not
cutting ourselves out of the process we
um all of our required a jurisdiction
elections will still happen and the only
difference between this and other
infrastructure projects that will be
attached to a certificate that gets
approved by the puc
well I'm up
understood would these permits then
happen
um concurrently with the site evaluation
process by the puc or afterward so the
the question is
will these slow down the process
our our process I mean it won't slow
down any more than the normal process
required for achieving a Wetlands permit
or an aot permit or whatever required
for the facility
um uh what the
um
so is when the whoever is working on the
development project or the
infrastructure project they will be
informed of the
um permits they need to in order for
them to move forward with their project
so
um it is on the developer to obtain the
environmental approvals they need and
like I said in other cases if there's a
a jurisdictional we have something Army
Corps has something fish and game has
something we all just do our work and
the um the developer or the person
pursuing the permits house to you know
obtains all of them separately the only
difference here is that to um show that
those have been obtained once they've
gone through our process they get
attached to the certificate just to
verify that this project has achieved
the environmental permits it needs
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman yes I just wanted
to to ask
the Deputy Commissioner if I think it
would be in follow-up to my colleague's
question if it'd be helpful to refer to
it's uh section 363 D7 application for
certificate bottom of page four top of
page five of the amendment
Roman numeral three it says each
application
referring to the the main application
shall contain sufficient information to
satisfy the application requirements of
each state agency having jurisdiction
under state or federal law to regulate
any aspect of the construction or
operation of the proposed facility and
shall include each agency's completed
application forms which shall be
contemporaneously filed with the state
agency having jurisdictions exactly yes
sir and and and the only thing I'll add
is uh well I know it hasn't been
introduced and you guys will debate it
as I noted in the letter from as the the
commissioner noted in his letter
um we did offer technical assistance to
representative bows in terms of some of
the changes and I know they're reflected
in the Chairman's Amendment he'll be
bringing forward to clarify some of
these uh including the appeal process
portion of this
all right I'll allow one more question
and then we have a move move on we have
a lot of public voices that want to be
heard here this morning so
representative Wendy Thomas you get the
last question yay thank you Mr chair
um I am as has been sort of uh referred
to in the last few questions I'm
concerned about the loss of
environmental impact evaluation I'm kind
of a you know save the world save the
whales kind of gal here
um I understand you're going to be
involved in permits I have concerns that
that testing May um may be dropped
um in in particular I'm looking at lines
13 and 14 on page four that says all
environmental impacts or effects are
adequately regulated by other federal
state or local statutes rules or
ordinances Des is not specifically
called out can you show me in the bill
where Des is mandated to be part of this
process
um all of the existing state statutes
that exist that require folks that if
they impact a Wetlands they have to get
a Wetlands permit if they're going to do
alteration of terrain they have to
obtain an alteration alteration of
terrain permit the uh those statutes
aren't in question here today and
um and the references to the bill refer
to those existing statutes as still
being the law of the land and I'm still
we will still continue to follow our
statutes and regulations as they exist
and will
inform this process of when our
requirements have been met
follow up thank you
um and does that include um for example
testing of soil for uh environmental
contaminations and or air whatever is
required to meet one of our permits now
will be
um still required to meet a permit um
whether it's going through this process
or not so the all
um I can assure you New Hampshire New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services would not be supporting this
bill if we thought in any way shape or
form it reduced our ability to fulfill
our responsibilities under federal and
state statute to protect the environment
and natural resources of this state and
what we have jurisdiction over I would
argue and why we support the bill and
improved process in terms of deciding
will improve our ability to make sure on
the environmental requirements are met
in a better coordinated better
structured and more efficient process so
we are here supporting this bill because
we think it'll lead to better outcomes
across the board including the
environmental thank you thank you
commissioner we really appreciate you
being here to testify on this bill and
giving us the Department's perspective
we appreciate the opportunity thank you
chairman and members and now I'd like to
get the utility perspective on this
question by calling on Michael Licata
good morning Mr locata
good morning
for the record Michael Licata
representing eversource energy I
understand you have numerous pink cards
and much of what I would testify to has
already been covered by previous
speakers uh eversource does support uh
House Bill 609 as introduced I do
understand there's an amendment that I
grabbed this morning I have not had an
opportunity to see that or review it so
we reserve judgment on changes proposed
in the amendment but as introduced the
company does support
the legislation
our view uh just to briefly Echo uh what
others had said is that all stakeholders
whether they're the public a
municipality a regulator or a developer
should want a clear process that is
understood by all and uh consistently
applies the law as you've heard the
current SEC process
has its shortcomings in these areas that
is due to a number of structural changes
with unintended consequences that were
adopted by the legislature several years
ago with the best of intentions to
provide agencies with additional
flexibility to address some of the
workload and scheduling concerns that
you have heard
we believe that uh putting the depart
the Public Utilities Commission in
charge of uh application reviews uh is
is a logical Choice as you have heard
that is a body that has expertise
knowledge and resources to handle large
and complicated adjudicative proceedings
as they do today we too share concerns
about resources uh with the the
department and certainly uh support
efforts to uh address that so that all
parties can have uh consistency of
timelines and the required staff support
we also believe that further
strengthening the
um
post application enforcement process by
putting the Department of Environmental
excuse me Department of energy in charge
the SEC administrator under the the doe
is logical as well and will provide
efficiencies for for those members of
the public or municipality that have
concerns post-construction that a
project is conforming to the terms of
their permit application
with that I'd be happy to answer any
questions that the committee may have
thank you we appreciate the utility
perspective on
the legislation
seeing no questions from the committee
oh thank you for your testimony and I
will point out that the
Amendment does
place the cited administrators the site
evaluation process administrator under
the commission not on the department of
energy
and with that we'll now try to get some
perspective from the business and
industry sector by calling on Mike
Skelton from the business and industry
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee thank you for the
opportunity to be here today
my name is Mike Skelton I'm the
president CEO of the business industry
Association of New Hampshire we're a New
Hampshire Statewide Chamber of Commerce
State manufacturing association and
leading business advocate we represent
more than 400 businesses across the
state of New Hampshire that collectively
employ more than a hundred thousand
individuals and contribute nearly five
billion dollars to our state's economy
um
I know you have a lot of testimony to
get to I'm passing around a copy of our
formal testimony for your review so
rather than read that I'll just offer a
few General comments
um and then I'd be happy to answer any
questions if I can be helpful
um
as I'm sure is an issue and a priority
for you the cost of energy is a high
public policy priority for our
organization and has been for many years
um one of the challenges that I also
know that you're aware of is that being
part of a regional energy Market
we don't have as many tools necessarily
or levers that we can pull to solve that
issue for our state alone
in our view though
citing and improving our citing process
is one of if not the most important
levers that we do control here in our
state that we should look to as a way to
lower the cost of energy sustainably in
the future
we're here in support of House Bill 609
we consider it one of our higher
priority legislative issues this session
as others have already testified we
think this bill and the efforts it puts
forth will result in a more stable clear
consistent citing process that will
support the development of projects we
need to lower our energy costs
and those projects will run the gamut of
all different types of Technology
however I will say and I I think this is
informed by conversations I have with
developers
um energy experts folks who closely work
in this area that in all likelihood the
energy we're going to be developing
going forward is going to be renewable
energy sources and I think in our view
renewable energy sources need this
improved process it will benefit them
and it will ensure that we can develop
these resources and strengthen our our
pool of resources for the future
have others have noted our current
process has some flaws and some issues
and in our view it doesn't serve the
best interests of our state at this time
particularly when we are faced with an
energy crisis and the need to lower
costs
as has already been stated again I think
we would point to similar flaws with the
part-time nature of the SEC has really
outlived its its lifespan its useful
lifespan in our state and the resulting
process is not stable or clear or
consistent for the critical decision
making we need when we're looking at
building new energy infrastructures and
the study committees that have been held
in 2021 and 2022 by and large in
reviewing the reports and having staff
who participated in those sessions reach
those same conclusions and we thank the
committee for their their work in those
areas
if there's one takeaway from those study
committees that I think is important
from a overall perspective is that the
status quo simply isn't working
those study committees we couldn't we
wouldn't keep going back to the well
with the work of those study committees
in this issue being coming up year after
year if there wasn't a problem here that
needs to be fixed
so I think that's one imperative that I
would leave you with here today is that
this is a real issue it's going to be
important for the future of our state
looking out over the next 10 20 30 40
years and we need a process that is more
I just want to note here for the record
and this has been touched on by others
from our view what this bill does and
doesn't do
we do believe the bill makes the process
more efficient and more effective
but in our reading in our close review
of this it does not lessen the standards
required of a project
and it does not lessen the opportunities
for public participation
nor does it diminish the requirements
expected of developers attached to my
formal testimony is a side by side of
the RSA specifically focused on the
public participation that has been
raised as others have mentioned as a
concern here and I just want to share
our view on this
you know there are significant
opportunities ahead to transform our
energy sector there's a lot of exciting
changes happening new technology coming
online or technology becoming more
affordable at the federal level as
you're all aware there's been
significant legislation that has created
new incentive tens of billions of
dollars of incentives in the inflation
reduction act and States across our
country are going to be competing and
working to attract those incentives and
attract the development that comes with
those incentives to their state
and I have a concern we are concerned
that New Hampshire will not be best
positioned to take advantage of those
opportunities unless we strengthen our
citing process and I would note in
addition that this is not just a state
issue that there has been bipartisan
interest and discussion ongoing for the
better part of a year about Federal
permitting and citing reform because
there is a recognition at that level as
well that if we're going to take
advantage of these incentives and
develop more renewable energy we need to
fix Federal citing and permitting reform
as well
um I just wanted to close with one uh to
cite someone else who I believe I don't
think Dawn crease is in the room today I
don't think he could be here but I was
able to
see his letter that he submitted today
um and uh don is a very eloquent speaker
and so
I think he put it really succinctly in
his letter and I just wanted to read
that for the record when he was speaking
on why the puc is the right fit in terms
of being the solution for moving the SEC
Authority in this in his letter he says
the process of deciding what should be
built becomes the province of a body
that is singularly focused on the energy
needs of the state as a whole
it also requires a tribunal with the
capacity to conduct complex contested
administrative proceedings effectively
efficiently and fairly
I just think that really encapsulates
what this bill is all about the problem
we're trying to solve and how important
it is that we get this right thank you
for your time this morning I'd be happy
to take any questions thank you we
appreciate your testimony here this
morning
representative Doug Thomas has a
question for you
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
you made mention and I will expand it on
you know as we grow our renewable energy
projects specifically either offshore
wind or major solar projects that will
require additional transmission lines to
get you know usable energy to everybody
will this bill and its uh amendment
should be adopted make it a lot easier
for those transmission lines for our
renewable energy projects to be built so
that we can enjoy the benefits of the
renewable energies thank you for the
question I don't think I wouldn't say
this makes uh the development of those
transmission lines easier that's not the
word I would use I would say I think
this bill creates a process by which
that type of infrastructure will be able
to be fairly and effectively assessed
and uh equitably decided upon but your
question is an extremely important one
because
there is no doubt that the singular
challenge we are going to face with
bringing on board more renewable energy
resources is going to be the
transmission that connects them to the
hubs of demand
and and this is I I could uh send the
committee hundreds of articles
from across the country on this exact
issue and how States and our federal
government are well aware that we are
facing a massive challenge with building
the transmission needed to connect new
resources that we build with where it
needs to go and be consumed and state
citing and federal citing is going to be
a huge part of making sure that we're
able to take advantage of those new
opportunities
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question you know in New
Hampshire I get feedback from people
from not only just in New Hampshire but
all of New England we sort of have a
very bad negative reputation um if you
look at Northern Pass whether you're in
favor of against it millions and
millions of dollars was spent and
nothing was accomplished literally uh
the Antrim win project took I think five
or six years to get permitted two full
applications and it's less than 30
megawatts so with this build you think
kind of send a message that we're at
least being a little bit more open to
new energy projects in New Hampshire and
it's not just not going with the uh you
know not my backyard syndrome uh don't
build anything here anywhere as long as
it's in New Hampshire will this help in
our view absolutely thank you for the
question I I think we need to
demonstrate that New Hampshire is open
for business and we have a stable
consistent process that is going to
treat projects fairly and it's not about
making the process easier for projects I
want to emphasize that there's nothing
here that diminishes the standards that
they have to overcome but to a question
that was raised earlier around timing
you mentioned that there has been
several projects where the existing
process has not result in a decision in
the required amount of time I think
that's the key
if the current statute says you have to
issue a certificate within 365 days and
we're not doing that that's not a stable
consistent process
and whether and I I would bet and this
goes for developers of anything whether
it's housing whether it's public
infrastructure whether it's anything
that you need to they want to know
what's the process what's the timeline
is it consistent and so if you have a
project in your your record this the
process says we'll get you a decision in
365 days they want to know up or down
within that 365 days
in my view a success would be whether or
not the SEC is approving or denying
projects if it can do that quicker
that's going to be a better process
because that's going to give more
consistency and understanding and
stability to the process process that
developers have to evaluate when they're
considering making Investments here in
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman and this is
actually not a question just I have to
make a statement for the record that my
other company I founded is a member of
Bia and I'm personally a member of their
technology committee
thank you for letting us know that
representative Christian has a question
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
um this is sort of a follow-up to
representative Thomas's question so you
mentioned that you think most projects
going forward will be Renewables which
is um obviously something I'm happy to
hear uh do you think given that it would
be appropriate to take this opportunity
to change the pricing structure of the
permit application so renewable projects
aren't charged 10 times per kilowatt or
at least aren't penalized for being
larger than 40 megawatts yeah um there's
been a lot of questions about that today
and I would encourage uh there may be
others who could come and speak to the
committee to explain the historic
reasoning behind that fee structure but
I want to I guess say as a matter of
um you know our view on this the fee
structure is a policy issue
the legislature can set whatever fee
structure you like and that will create
incentives or disincentives for
different projects
my understanding however is the
historical reasoning behind the fee
structure which I believe is not changed
in the proposal either the as introduced
or the amendment is that it was around
generating the right amount of income to
support what a project would cost moving
through the SEC process and that was the
only reason behind the fee structure is
I understand it so I don't believe there
was any intent to
punish or disincentivize or incentivize
certain types of development there was a
methodology behind it and I think there
could perhaps be others who are involved
in the history of the SEC who could
speak to that better than I
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair in your side
by side comparison
it looks like the current law and I'm
looking at on page two of that printout
sections um four and five under current
laws seem to be missing under 609 so I
just want to confirm that the Bia is
comfortable with eliminating some
hearings investigations or studies
reasonable studies and investigations
those two sections yeah thank you
representative in totality in looking at
the comparison we thought that this does
not diminish the public participation
opportunities so I realize the structure
is different you know the paragraphs in
some cases have been streamlined or
shortened I think that's a matter of
policy on your part to determine does
the statute list the intended number of
opportunities and hearings but in
totality we view the process and how
this is proposed in House Bill 609 as
being ample comparable and does not
diminish the opportunity for public
input follow-up follow-up thank you and
with this shortened schedule might there
be an unintended consequences for
businesses
I'm sorry could you explain a little
further what you mean by unintended
consequences well we
are
um
playing to after the project's already
been started or after it's been
completed so would there in your opinion
would this shortened schedule could it
lead to unintended consequences like
that
well just to clarify thank you for the
question I'm not sure uh I would I would
phrase as a shortened schedule I think
what we view is this process will
streamline the ability for a project to
be completed on time through the process
through the the intended initial goal
time of within 365 days now whether a
project moves through that 365-day
window in one month six months or the
full 12 months is entirely dependent
upon the quality of their application
and what they put forth what the nature
of it is and how that is then
adjudicated through the process I think
in our view we we the advantage we see
to this is that under the puc which is
an existing adjudicative body they will
better be able to effectively move
projects through that process and
uncover any issues that need to be
resolved in a more timely fashion than
in the current uh process you know it
was I'll Echo what others have said
before me that when you have our
existing process that struggles to
bring together quorums and you have
membership that well well-intentioned
are not experts in the processes that
they are reviewing I think that leads to
delay and potentially can lead to
oversights and unintended consequences
that we don't want to see
thank you okay thank you very much we
appreciate you being here to give us the
perspective of the business uh community
before we turn to a perspective from the
consumer community
I will alert you to the fact that it is
now 10 35 or so 10 33 actually and we
were scheduled to open a public hearing
on House Bill 142 at 10 30.
obviously we're not going to make that
time period
I will also point out that we have a
hard stop of one o'clock this afternoon
because several members of our committee
are committed to other activities
beginning at one o'clock
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
continue this public hearing and we'll
start the public hearing on House Bill
142.
insufficient time to finish it by one
o'clock
so let's try to get this one done by 11
or 11 30 at the latest so that we'll
have time to do 142 before 1 o'clock
complete 142 before one o'clock with
that said I'll Now call on Mark Brown of
the consumer energy Alliance to give us
the consumer's perspective on this
legislation
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee
for the record my name is Mark Brown
vice president of state affairs for
Consumer Energy Alliance ceas a
nationwide Association made up of both
energy producers and consumers looking
to advance all of the above energy
policies that deliver affordable and
reliable energy
and environmentally responsible energy
to families and businesses I'm here
today in support of the bill
um I'm not going to repeat I think Mr
Skelton pretty much said a lot of the
things that I wanted to say I think this
bill balance is competing interests
um I will answer one question that
representative Thomas answered earlier
about investment a few years ago at a
New Hampshire business and industry
Association Symposium
represented from Barclays was speaking
and said that you know the current
citing laws in New Hampshire were
basically sending us to an invest a
signal to investors that New Hampshire
was not open for for investment for
infrastructure
so I just wanted to you know kind of
affirm what he said
um
we know Regional you know high energy
costs I won't I won't repeat that but
electricity demand is expected to
increase over the next 10 years or so by
approximately 15 20 according to ISO a
lot of that's due to increase Demand on
the electricity and then excuse me the
transportation and heating sectors from
electrification so we are going to need
energy infrastructure to suit our
growing electricity demand
and I think Mr Skelton is right when he
says that most of those resources are
going to come from Renewables I don't
see any new additional natural gas you
know Greenfield natural gas pipelines
being into the region to develop natural
gas plants or anything like that so I
think any fear that this bill is
anti-renewable is a little bit of
unfounded maybe
um
and the again the process the public
process hasn't changed and I also want
to follow up something Mr Beamer said
about resiliency it's important that the
bill is this bill is not
structured in a way that seems to be
partisan it's not kind of trying to rig
to suit the current Administration or
the current puc or you know whatever
current uh Authority and state agencies
or what party is in charge so I think
that's important and it's this is not a
stark departure from what a lot of other
states do a lot of other states have you
know their Public Utilities commissions
or public service commissions kind of in
charge of citing either directly or or
are accompanied by some other agency so
this is not a stark departure from that
as far as you know electric transmission
goes and the need to you know deliver
Renewables there's an interesting you
know a little headline in Bloomberg
green yesterday that said uh there's no
transition without transmission so I
think if you want to see renewable
energy developed we're going to need to
meet that demand you know we're going to
need to lower cost you know 60 percent
of the Americans right now
living paycheck to paycheck they don't
have five hundred dollars in savings
they can't afford a thousand dollar
emergency so the developer of you know
infrastructure is going to be important
so I don't want to take up too much more
time I know a lot of people are here to
speak so with that I'll take any
questions
thank you appreciate your testimony
giving us the consumer perspective
seeing no questions from the committee
I'll uh thank you and move along and
call on David public cover
of the Appalachian Mountain Club to give
all right so are we on
all right thank you uh chairman Vose
Vice chairman Thomas members of the
committee my name is David publikover
I'm senior staff scientist and assistant
director of research for the Appalachian
Mountain club based in Gorham New
Hampshire I'm testifying on behalf of
the AMC in opposition to hb609
uh the AMC has a long history of
involvement in issues of energy facility
sighting in the state we have been
interveners in the permitting of several
projects before the SEC and we're
actively involved engaged in the
extensive legislative and Regulatory
process the sb99 process that updated
the sec's structure and rules less than
a decade ago
if the legislature is going to dismiss
the efforts of the many people who
participated in that effort and
eliminate the SEC there should be a
strong reason
we know of No Such reason
we support the development of new clean
energy infrastructure in the state both
generation and transmission to address
the critical impacts of fossil fuel
burning on our climate we also recognize
that the current permitting process can
be improved we know that it is
inefficient and it can put a burden on
the agency heads who serve on the
committee however we believe that any
changes must retain the important
benefits of the current process under
the guise of improving the efficiency of
Permitting hb609 would eliminate or
weaken many Provisions that provide
important protection to New Hampshire
citizens communities and environment
among the specific concerns we have with
this legislation are
currently decisions are made by a body
the site evaluation committee that
contains a diversity of expertise from
different state departments as well as
to members of the public ensuring that
multiple perspectives will be present
during deliberations
well the puc has expertise in many areas
evaluating impacts to natural and
cultural resources is not among them
eliminating in States resource agencies
and public members from a
decision-making role will significantly
narrow the scope of discussion during
deliberations
and determining whether a project has an
unreasonable adverse impact on the
natural environment goes far beyond
things like Wetlands permits and
alteration of trains permits
second hb609 would reduce the role of
the council for the public which is one
of the most important features of the
current structure providing a neutral
party to represent the public interest
in ensuring a full vetting of
application materials
making the council optional at the
discretion of the puc in the doe weakens
this important protection of the public
interest
and finally hb609 would eliminate the
current SEC rules that were developed in
2015 with significant public involvement
these rules include extensive guidance
on application requirements as well as
factors that must be considered in
making the required findings there is
the potential that the new rules that
would have to be adopted by the puc
could weaken consideration of many
environmental and social impacts
we urge the sponsor to withdraw this
legislation and work with the full range
of stakeholders to identify potential
improvements to the energy facility
permitting process that repaint these
important components this legislation
rather than making targeted beneficial
adjustments takes to throw the baby out
with the bathwater approach that would
undo the hard work done less than a
decade ago and lead to an uncertain
result with potentially negative
consequences for New Hampshire's
communities and environment
this committee should vote the bill in
expedient to legislate and we thank you
for the opportunity to provide these
comments
thank you for your testimony questions
representative
Corman
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question if I understand
correctly you said that there are
environmental impacts or potential
environmental impacts that that go
beyond what Des would be permitting or
or is in charge of Permitting I'm
wondering if you can provide us with
some examples please yeah there are many
things uh
such as impacts to rare plants and
natural communities which have no
statutory protection uh impacts of
habitat fragmentation which are not uh
mentioned in any legislation or
statutory protection other than the SEC
rules as a factor that must be
considered so these are some examples of
broader uh environmental impacts that
are not specifically covered in statute
and are not specifically protected
resources but form part of the the
larger issue of an unreasonable adverse
impact on the natural environment
follow-up
thank you have these issues actually
come up in previous SEC deliberations
yes they have uh in many of the ones
we've done uh in the permitting of uh
the granite reliable wind project which
we initially opposed in part but
ultimately ended up withdrawing that
that opposition uh one of the
significant impacts was on high
elevation habitat for bicknell's thrush
which is one of the rarest migratory
songbirds in the United States but which
is not it designated endangered species
uh
the project was required to uh do
considerable compensatory protection of
high elevation habitat as compensation
for the impacts again New Hampshire
fishing game was though not a member of
the SEC was actively involved in that
and it's it's unclear whether the puc
would have the you know how they would
approach something that's outside their
certainly uh impacts to rare species and
natural communities were a large issue
in the northern pass process though that
the SEC decision never got to the point
of making a finding on impacts to the
sorry uh representative Wendy Thomas has
a question thank you
um thank you Mr chair
um I'm intrigued with these um aspects
that are not covered by um permitting um
with the northern pass I assume some of
these these uh topics were raised rare
plants endangered uh animals that kind
of thing
um how were they raised if they weren't
covered by the permitting did the public
raise them well they were raised by by
interveners uh I believe fish and games
input discussed them though I think they
believe that appropriate accommodations
were made but again if we rely on Des to
cover the environmental permitting
again the impacts to rare plants and
natural communities are not specifically
statutorily protected they fall under
the broader purview of the the required
finding oh follow-up
follow-up yes so would you say that the
input from
um
non-agencies in the public has served
well in this process
I think it has I think it's raised
important issues and it's you know it's
brought information to the process uh
you know certainly The Nature
Conservancy brought a lot of important
information to the process uh so I think
maintaining that level of public input
is important
thank you
representative Doug Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question
so if I understand you you had you
meaning the public had a voice in
Northern Pass and brought up some of
some of those issues even though they
weren't statutorily required
and from what I've heard today there has
been no lusting of public input in this
new bill
why would you think that you would not
have any say so in any of the subjects
that you brought up since the public is
going to have as much input ability as
we heard from the previous testimonies
it's not a matter of bringing the
information into the process you know as
long as the right of
the public to intervene uh is maintained
in the legislation that will be there
it's a matter of who gets to make the
decision and reducing the resource
agencies which have greater expertise in
this issues from a decision-making
process you know part of the
decision-making body to an information
providing body we think lessens the
consideration that these issues may get
during the decision making because the
puc is that's not
you know they know how to run a process
but impacts to the natural environment
is not where their expertise lies
so again it's a matter of who gets to
okay seeing no further questions from
the committee I want to thank you for
offering your perspective on this
legislation here today
and next we'll get some perspective from
the
uh labor union committee alcohol on Alan
good morning good morning
thank you Mr chairman honorable
committee members my name is Alan RAF
and I'm come before you here on behalf
of the New Hampshire AFL-CIO and our
over 35 000 members in the state of New
Hampshire to urge you to vote to pass on
hb609
um energy facilities in New Hampshire
are extremely complicated the process is
a thorough and multi-faceted process
which is necessary to ensure that the
projects that are approved truly do
benefit our state
when a new energy infrastructure project
is approved it's not only the New
Hampshire rate payers and taxpayers that
benefit from these projects but also New
Hampshire workers
so typically energy developers partner
with trade unions to ensure that the
project is constructed with the best
trained and experienced trades people
and because trade unions ongoing
training and focus on worker safety
um because many of these projects
require a large number of workers unions
manage Staffing to ensure there are
workers enough workers to keep
construction schedules on track and to
minimize delays on those projects it
takes thousands of workers plan build
and after completion maintain these
finished products New Hampshire AFL-CIO
represents tens of thousands of people
that would make up the prospective
Workforce on these projects
so that's why we support the bill
because these projects have not been
happening and we have a great need for
energy infrastructure in the state our
organization's membership is made up of
electricians linemen laborers
longshoremen Carpenters painters and
Engineers that will ensure that these
projects are built on time on budget and
within the guidelines that these
projects should be completed as far as
safety maintaining how these uh in the
case of endangered animals or plants to
make sure that these projects are in
compliance with keeping them safe and
making sure that the projects that are
built are you know they're protecting
the habitats of these animals and these
plants
um
the jobs that come with these projects
are New Hampshire jobs meaning that they
go to local workers in the community in
which these projects are being developed
these projects give good jobs and they
come with benefits and retirement plans
health insurance as well
as well as the added benefit of being
able to work where you live where many
of our workers have to take jobs that
are hundreds of thou or thousands of
miles away from New Hampshire away from
their families away from the New
Hampshire economy away from the rest of
their lives
um over the years various unions have
participated in the site evaluation
committee process on projects that
impact our membership and Union
participation has come in the form of
public input serving as expert Witnesses
or participating in the docket as full
interveners
I personally served as an attorney for
the ibw and their capacity as
interveners in these cases and from my
experience and the experience of others
who've worked on uh worked through this
process we've developed several concerns
that we believe hb609 takes steps to
address one the role of the SEC and it's
important to the state citizens and our
workers has grown to require more than
just a part-time committee structure
given the importance of these issues and
expert panel supported with professional
staff is needed and while it's not
addressed in hv609 we believe that it is
also crucial that the state provide
resources to adequately staff the SEC as
we've heard before and I know that the
concern a lot of people in the room who
are opposed to this bill is that the
public is not going to have their voices
heard or their concerns have a place
where they're actually taken into
consideration when making a decision on
citing the project but I would also
posit that Mr Beamer is the only staff
member at the SEC officially and I think
that the public might be better served
by having more support more resources of
the puc and all the others who would be
involved if this legislation is passed
to actually take all their concerns read
the hundreds of pages of testimony the
evidence and the compelling stuff that
everyone who participates in the process
expects all the members that are going
to make these decisions and who are
weighing in on them actually read and
take the time to understand and just
having Mr Beamer to go through sort
through all the stuff by himself I think
is a difficult thing with all this
information that comes through number
two transferring the adjudicative duties
of the SEC to the puc would provide
consistency and expertise that can be
lacking in the current process as we've
talked about before that's currently
structured the sitting members the SEC
can handle any there can include any
number of people in over the past few
years upward of 40 different people have
served as SC member SCC members on
various dockets even with these people
many times getting a quorum for these
SEC hearings is a problem as we've heard
that's cause unexpected delays and that
costs money for the people who are
involved patches the businesses that are
involved but also the interveners who've
hired attorneys the members of public
who have spent days months years in some
cases coming down to sit through these
hearings
um three and finally uh hb609 maintains
an application and review process that
provides Clarity to the applicants and
the interested parties these can be
extremely complex projects not only in
terms of permitting but engineering
ordering and securing equipment and
ensuring required lab labor is available
unions we work far in advance to ensure
adequate labor is lined up for these
projects and as such we need to be able
to rely on a clear permitting process so
it is for these reasons this New
Hampshire AFL-CIO asks you to support
hb609 and I'd be happy to take any
questions thank you for your prospective
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question just a quick one so
what you were stating there not
Financial stood correctly the delays and
the current current site processing have
had an effect on our New Hampshire trade
unions correct oh yeah absolutely
follow up
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um can you tell me if the AFL-CIO has
any objections or concerns with recent
projects that have been authorized by
the current SEC
I I can't speak can you be more specific
and I'd be happy to get that answer to
you as far as which projects but there
are some no I'm saying if you could tell
me which projects you're referring to
I'd be happy to ask if
a follow-up our membership has had
issues okay follow up for clarification
yes I I think that um in your testimony
you
um raised objections or concerns uh for
projects and not so I'm just wondering
where that came from is that are you
projecting that there might be
objections and concerns or is that based
on history oh no we no I wasn't saying
that we had okay I wasn't saying that no
thank you
okay seeing a representative Christian
has a question
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
um so as you mentioned and as we've
heard you know there's a lot of concerns
that this process is very slow because
there just aren't enough people with the
expertise or with the time to address
them
um I guess I'm still concerned that you
know if this is just getting uh dumped
on three puc members we're still going
to have this problem we have to fund new
positions to support these cases anyway
so why not keep it as it is and just
fund some more support versus
putting it into the state government
that already has other responsibilities
and thank you for your question
representative
um so I think what many of you I don't
know how familiar you are with the
process or the how the MCC actually runs
and what goes on day to day but it's
already uh like I said there's one staff
member there and that person has a bunch
of other people that they have to
basically ask on a volunteer basis to
help them out sorting through all this
stuff
um so I would say that under this new
process the way that this bill is
proposed that there would be more
support and even if you weren't to hire
anybody else there would be it to have
some of the weight go to not just three
members because the way to think about
it isn't just that these three people
are going to be doing all the work it's
going to be everything else and it comes
into the process through this bill and
it wasn't just the SEC members doing the
work it was also the administrator and
the administrator's staff which
currently is lacking the position was
open for two years before Mr Beamer was
okay seeing no further questions for Mr
RAF I want to thank you for being here
thank you next we'll get the perspective
of The Nature Conservancy from Ms
good morning good morning chairman Vos
Vice chair Thomas and members of the
committee I do have a testimony letter
that's making its way around
um I wanted to start off by agreeing
with a few of the comments that have
made been made earlier we do agree with
and sorry I'm Meredith Hatfield
representing the nature conservancy we
agree with Mr locata from eversource
that
um in that we also want to clear and
understandable citing process
and it's actually been a kind of
exciting conversation this morning with
folks from a lot of different groups
including several legislators remarking
about our need to ensure that New
Hampshire doesn't lose out on federal
funds that could be coming to us and
also a great discussion about the need
for us to more rapidly deploy clean
energy
um I have not had the opportunity to see
the amendment so our testimony letter
does focus on the bill as um
as it originally was drafted
so I'm going to try to just cover things
that other people haven't so on page two
of our letter
um I wanted to raise just some questions
about agency roles
um
I do understand I think that the
amendment uh chairman Vos you just said
a few minutes ago moves the
administrator to the puc which we think
is appropriate and we actually agree
with the comments that were just made by
the AFL-CIO
about the need to adequately staff the
function wherever it it
um it ends up being
um
in terms of public deliberations I
wanted to point out that an important
part of the SEC is that it is required
to deliberate in public however and I've
provided you the statutory site the puc
has
um an exception under the right to no
law so the puc doesn't have to
deliberate in public
um
and we think that it is a really
important aspect of the SEC that it does
have to deliberate in public so we would
ask
that if you do move forward with this
bill that you would make that very clear
another aspect is the important role of
council for the public and House Bill
changes
that decision about Council for the
public being appointed changes the word
shall to May and allows it to be a
discretionary decision of the doe and we
would urge you to to continue to have
that be required so to use the word
shall
and I think that also raises some
questions for us around roles of
agencies
and if the doe is going to make a
decision about public counsel but the
doe Also may be a party in a case we
think that that raises some questions
that really should be thought through
very carefully
another issue about the duties and the
roles
um
relates to the whether the doe would be
participating
and would they also have to enforce and
how would the communication work between
the puc and the doe I'm sure that
they've been navigating those issues
since the the agency was created last
year but I think it's really important
for the public and for interveners to
understand who we can talk to and when
so could we talk to the administrator
clearly you can't talk to a puc
commissioner but would you be able to
talk to someone at doe so I think
spending some time thinking about
funding I did just mention that we we
agree that this is an important public
purpose and we were pleased to see that
General funds would be allocated to the
citing work we did find it to be a
little bit unclear around the use of the
filing fees because I think that section
18 of the bill
related to funding excuse me says that
monitoring and enforcement activities of
doe would be funded by the filing fees
and then the rest of the duties would be
General funded so we wanted to point out
that that was a little bit unclear to us
and we also wondered how
the doj's costs related to providing
public counsel how those would be paid
for and if any other agencies would be
able to recover the cost of
participating
um regarding rulemaking and the
effective date if House Bill 609 passes
it has an effective date of 60 days and
we think that that is
um not enough time to develop rules and
also ensure an appropriate transition
and we also share the views that AMC
just raised about the the importance of
the rules there are a lot of issues
covered in the rules as authorized by
existing provisions of the statute that
don't appear to be in House Bill 609
that we would urge you to include to
ensure that
some of the things that the AMC raised
in its testimony are still going to be a
part of the process because obviously
there are a lot of benefits from energy
infrastructure but I think it's um it's
important that we consider the
the potentially negative impacts and
have plans to mitigate those
foreign
with respect to the members of the SEC I
had the privilege of serving on the SEC
myself at one point when I was in state
service and I really did benefit greatly
from the different perspectives that
were brought by different agencies and I
would say particularly those that don't
have a permitting requirement and so
don't have sort of a regulatory
Authority but who have
um
deep expertise on economic development
Transportation
cultural resources and I know fish and
game was was mentioned previously and
and in terms of the signal that New
Hampshire is sending to developers I
would respectfully suggest that while
our citing process certainly could be
improved some of our other foundational
laws like the RPS and our lack of a
climate plan are really what is sending
a negative signal to people who might be
investing here
um so we would suggest that you find
this bill in expedient to legislate due
to all of these issues or if the
committee wishes to move forward with
this idea
to retain the bill and do some further
work on it I also wanted to just point
out that attorney Amy manzelli had to
leave but she did submit a letter she
has significant experience in several
several proceedings at the P at the SEC
so I would commend to you her very brief
letter
and then I also I have studied the study
committee report
which does make quite a few
recommendations
um that aren't in House Bill 609 and I
did
find it interesting that Senator Ruth
Ward who I believe was the chair of that
um most recent study committee did sign
in opposed to this bill I was hoping to
hear today what her concerns were but um
I haven't heard them yet
and I think
um
just to give you a statutory site on the
sections that provide rulemaking
Direction
um it is 162h 10 a which is related to
wind and
162h10b which is related to gas
pipelines and we think
um
it would be great and if the law was
changed to take some of those criteria
that are so important and make them
apply to all projects
and I think that's all I had thank you
questions representative Summers has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question you mentioned
there in your testimony that you were a
member of the SEC while you were a
member of that committee did you ever
witness the committee unable to be able
to create a quorum
thank you
um
I
it definitely
to have that many members from different
agencies be able to get together but I
would also point out you know the puc
does struggle with that as well and I
think there are some dockets
um the grid modernization docket I think
uh I'm not sure if it's closed but it
was started in 2015 I think and doesn't
have a conclusion and I know the current
default service investigation was
supposed to have a tech session last
week and was rescheduled to April so I
think it's a common challenge but
I certainly think that the process could
be improved
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair
um it it sounds pretty clear that that
we need to make some changes to the
committee and or process
um
uh on point four on page two of your
printout um you you talk about the
council for the public and you're you're
urging us to use the word shall
um I've noticed that you've not included
the consumer Advocate are you open to
including the consumer Advocate as a
shall partner in this process
um thank you for that question and I I
also had the privilege of serving as the
consumer Advocate a number of years ago
and my understanding is that
traditionally the OCA
because it is charged with representing
residential rate payers and SEC
proceedings don't involve rates
um that they the legislature didn't
contemplate a role but I I don't know if
if a consumer Advocate has actually
tried to participate because perhaps the
SEC would have allowed it
um I do think that
moving if you moved the SEC to the puc
it might be that the OCA would already
automatically be able to participate the
way that they do today in puc
proceedings there is
um a memorandum of understanding between
the two agencies that allows the OCA
um to participate anytime that
residential customers would be impacted
so I'm not sure it needs to be
explicitly in there but I would
certainly defer to um to Mr crease on
that follow-up would you like to see the
consumer Advocate included in this
process
um
you know it is a small agency with a lot
of of work to do before the puc
um
and if rate if a energy facility is
being cited and rate payers are not
contributing and and you know the rates
wouldn't be considered in an SEC case
I'm not sure
it's necessary I think if there were to
be a proposal for a power purchase
agreement between a utility and a
project that was cited that would go
before the puc and the OCA would
certainly
um participate uh Mr crease I did speak
with him about this and he did
um make a really good point that it
might be useful for the OCA to be at the
table at the outset so that when they
review the PPA you know they've been
able to
participate you know and not it that
perhaps it could be a foregone
conclusion by the time you reach the PPA
case representative Carmen has a
question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
so you've certainly given us several
shall we say constructive criticisms of
the bill
but one of the basic premises of the
bill is to move the site evaluation
process just directly into the puc
generally I I think it could be done
there are a lot of other states where
the puc has a site citing Authority but
without adequate Staffing and just
really careful attention to how all of
those non
um utility issues would be addressed you
know the the habitat the um economic
aspects
um you know things that are outside that
traditional puc jurisdiction I mean you
know if I was a commissioner needing to
take this on
I would want to make sure I had the
staff and I had the clear paths to get
the input that I needed to rule on
things that would be
you know traditionally outside of that
air you know traditionally the puc
balances the interests of rate payers
and utility shareholders
they are currently on the SEC so they do
serve but I think putting it all under
them I would it would be great to hear
from them you know how would they
set up their Staffing and how how would
they make sure that they got the
information they needed to make the
okay seeing no further questions I want
to thank Miss Hatfield for giving us her
perspective on this proposed legislation
and we'll call next on Joe Casey
who represents the IB ew
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee
um thank you for uh listening to my
testimony this morning I had prepared
but uh in respect of your time I'm just
going to I think Mr raft did a great job
as far
as representing Labor's view
um I just personally want I am a
business development rep for the
International Brotherhood of Electrical
Workers
in the ibw strongly supports uh hb609
the
my my position
um is a business development rep is for
to work with developers throughout New
England in our local unions in the New
England states
and I can tell you um
I I'm a resident of New Hampshire but I
spend most of my time in our surrounding
states and I've had a number of
developers tell me that they've they're
just not interested in trying to uh uh
get things going in in the state of New
Hampshire
um like I said I represent line workers
in electricians in the construction
branch
and um
uh we have two local unions here in the
state of New Hampshire one in Concord
and one in Barrington with training
centers and people that are ready to go
and and work in the industry and expand
in the industry
um but it's been a very difficult I
personally uh have been in front of the
SEC
and testified and uh is cumbersome and
very very difficult to do
that'll conclude my testimony
well thank you we appreciate that
perspective
see no questions from the committee
um come to these but is it a coincidence
I've been here for an hour and 15
minutes and very little of that has been
people who are opposed have been given
an opportunity to speak and I'm
wondering if that's a coincidence or not
just I'm I'm trying to mix them in mix
well we won't close the proceeding what
we may do is we may recess it till next
Monday
we won't close it
okay
so Jim Monahan from the New England
power generous generators Association is
uh thank you Mr chairman and certainly I
will be quick in light of the folks who
have traveled here today
um I didn't sign up in uh opposition or
in support of the bill because
um I haven't seen the uh the amendment
in any detail
um but
um I do have some experience working
with developers before the site
evaluation committee and that has ranged
from the CV C3 project a number of New
Hampshire transmission projects a couple
of solar projects uh wind project
transfer all these things have gone
through the set evaluation committee and
so in reading and following what the
commission has done uh which led to this
legislation there were three things that
I was if the legislation is going to go
forward there were three things that I
was hoping to address and I think some
of them are and some of them are not
um the first is the question about the
um what do you do with uh Apple I do
have a client that's going to be filing
a 50 megawatt solar project application
this spring before the site evaluation
committee and we wanted to understand
what would happen if the a law changed
while the application had been filed I
think the legislation addresses that and
the second to the last session so
section so I appreciate that the other
question uh is with regard to the
transfer of the certificate when uh one
cooperation purchases the power plant
from another one there's a change in
there in that it trans it looks as
though it ensures that that's an
administrative proceeding you don't have
to go through a long adjudicated
proceeding my only question is whether
that should be undertaken by by the
commission or is this more of an
Enforcement issue that should be
undertaken by the department of energy
and I don't have a strong feeling I I
haven't read the amendment enough to
know if that's that's clear but then the
larger issue which I'll touch on today
but I don't have a resolution for you is
on this question around
um
uh how should we deal with uh existing
certificate holders these are my clients
which are the uh the large power plants
uh if they do uh refuelings make changes
put in batteries upgrade their
transmission facilities our general view
is that we shouldn't take those
processes and additions and run them
through the whole same process that a
Greenfield side would
the normal mechanism I guess a mechanism
to address that is whether or not the
addition is sizable and I do see in the
amendment there is direction to the
commission to come up with a definition
of what a sizable addition is
because there isn't one in the rules now
it's kind of done by historically what
they have been I don't know if at some
point the legislature might want to
offer some direction to the commission
on that and then a timeline would be
helpful as well I know I'm involved in
some roommate Vikings that the Public
Utilities Commission that are underway
that have lasted longer than World War
II so a rapid a more rapid process in
that front would be helpful but perhaps
the more challenging issue is uh if a
facility uh is making an addition uh
it's and it's somewhat sizable
um uh uh you know maybe uh in this I
think we'll see a lot of this over the
next five to ten years where uh because
of the uh inflation reduction act
there'll be a lot of investment in
upgrades to facilities so there's going
to be facilities with uh where
certificates
um if they're if they fall inside or
outside of the sizable question there's
two questions here one is if you are
deemed not sizable and therefore not
under the jurisdiction of the site
evaluation committee do you default to
just local Planning and Zoning I think
folks would want to avoid that because
they might not have the expertise to to
review it but if you're deemed to be
under the jurisdiction and you're doing
something within the same footprint it's
the same 400 day long process so
um that's very much in the weeds and so
I just wanted to kind of put that on the
table I'm happy to work with the house
the Senate the Asia the state agencies
are working this to try to tease up some
of these some particulars
okay thank you
representative McWilliams has a question
thank you chair uh real quick so would
you consider sizable to be say half the
size of the existing facility or greater
for an addition
I'm working with my clients to try to
come up with this and we're looking at
both with regard to the footprint of the
facility and then perhaps judging it
based upon the uh the the name plate so
if you and 50 is a number that has been
bounced around surrounded if you're
underneath the 50 nameplate then it
would be deemed not sizable but I'm
ahead of my client on that so don't tell
see no further questions I will thank
you and next I'll call on
hello my name is Terrace cuckman I'm a
resident of 12 Brookwood Drive in
Concord I'm a former uh intervener uh
and survivor of the northern pass
contest I also took part in the SEC
activities and in the interest of full
disclosure uh in my prior life I was a
manufacturing engineer and a quality
engineer and I lived for identifying
waste getting rid of it so that we could
make things better faster and cheaper
having said that I look at this bill and
I'm saying what we saw with the SEC was
time consuming I agree
but my objection
to this bill is that it's discounting
disqualifying
um
a voice and a vote
I I appreciate that looking under a
microscope but this legislation that all
the voices that were heard during the
Northern Pass were hurt and going
forward I can accept that that will be
the case would I do not
believe
is right is
discounting and eliminating the
layperson if you will from the actual
vote in my prior life I had to convince
lay people all the time on the specifics
of engineering concerns and it was
incumbent upon me
to make them understand before they
rendered a vote discounting them in this
process is not the way to go
so I request that you rule in expedient
to legislate as it is written I thank
you
if there are any questions if not thank
you we appreciate you giving us your
perspectives seeing no questions
Karen Payne
of Effingham
thank you and Karen would it be
acceptable to start imposing a
two-minute time limit on testimony
I'm I'm not I I can't answer that
question
yeah I'll keep going
so thank you for everything you're doing
I'm sorry that representative Thomas
stepped out because I did want to thank
him for the point he made at the
beginning
we do not want to scare away new energy
projects
um I was thinking maybe he would be an
awesome person to take the lead on
looking at page eight and making those
figures more attractive for some of
these renewable energy projects to come
to New Hampshire but
um thank you chairman also spoke very
clearly on behalf of the Public
Utilities Commission about the costs
that is totally understandable
um
I guess before I get to the to money I
just wanted to to say I wanted to ask
this committee to be for thinking for
the State of New Hampshire and energy
solutions that need to come toward us
looking local perhaps preventing
too many of these huge transmission
lines that out that were threatened by
they will change the face of New
Hampshire they will change the quality
of our life
um I think that to work on those you
have to be bonded where's our lad from
the AFL-CIO gone already I think his
local men won't be able to work on some
of these projects so there's a little
inconsistency
and that brings me to the money money
can often be very manipulative and I
fear there's a lot of money in this room
and I fear we're being manipulated I
think if we would follow money it would
take us right to the AFL-CIO I don't
think he came here on his own I think
somebody asked him to speak
um I think that money will flatten
historic resources Community Resources
environmental resources that are
irreplaceable and we really want to be
careful about putting money in front of
Priceless things that we value here in
New Hampshire no doubt the puc would be
efficient and I think the people who are
opposed will say no doubt it will be
predictable if just a handful of people
behind closed doors make these decisions
so
why does New Hampshire deserve to have
the first Primary in the nation
do we deserve to have the first Primary
in the nation
we listen we talk we talk politics
year-round we entertain many sides of
each question and we take our voices
seriously
this bill ignores the fact that we are
deeply interested and indeed the process
needs an upgrade
please do not depart
from the public not just maybe having a
say
but have the wider public
in a seat at the table for this
the precedent is that the voice of the
people of New Hampshire is respected
beneficial
okay thank you for your perspective
seeing no further questions from uh this
uh representative McWilliams as a
question
thank you for your testimony and thank
you for coming out today in terms of the
people having a voice The Proposal right
now is the three SEC Commissioners what
is your proposal for the public to
actually have a voice what would that
look like
well it certainly wouldn't be too
appointed people behind closed doors
thank you think there's room for
creativity there but
okay seeing no more questions we'll next
good morning good morning Jeannie Menard
from Deerfield if time is being limited
may I give my one minute to the society
for the protection of New Hampshire
Force if they are going to be speaking
uh okay thank you if you would like to
Yes
um
let's see I do have a card from Matt
uh good morning thank you Mr chairman
um just for the record I'm Matt Leahy
I'm the public policy director for the
society for the protection of New
Hampshire Forest I did hand out our
written testimony prior to the hearing
so I'm not going to reread that I did
just want to make one point and I know
there's been a lot of discussion about
um that the current structure of the SEC
is a weakness and an issue
um you know we would respectfully
disagree we think it's actually a
strength
um of the current our current citing law
here
um and having that
and certainly the members of the puc who
are on the SEC have a certain set of
expertise and skills and and that's
important to have you know when it comes
to time to make a decision on whether or
not to approve or not approve an energy
project but
we also need those additional voices and
and and set of expertise that's that is
there right now in the current structure
of the secs that may and that obviously
includes some of the other state
agencies but also those public members
you know they certainly bring their own
insight and background that is important
to make you know when it when the time
comes to make that decision so you know
certainly you know we can have an
efficient process to make these
decisions but you know ultimately
the public does need to have faith and
trust that whatever the outcome is made
in for a particular project you know was
reached fairly you know all the
information was reviewed and looked at
you know the
um
you know there was there was you know
robust input
um in the project from the public right
from the get-go
um so
um again we do oppose
um the bill and I would just add one
thing you know if there is a concern
that uh the SEC
needs more staff needs more resources I
mean that is certainly something uh the
um the members of the House and Senate
can do by you know adding those
resources you know if they need
additional staff if they need a legal
counsel to you know answer any questions
relative to the law and the rules
um you know you know that is something
that I think can be done relatively
easily so again we do oppose the bill
um but I'm happy to take any questions
thank you for bringing the forest
society's voice to the table
representative McWilliams has a question
same question what would public
participation look like for you under
this bill I read your testimony are you
considering you know there's the
attorney piece and then there's actual
public members
yeah I would again you know we would
maintain the current structure which
does include those public members you
know the role of the um public Office of
Public Council needs to be
you know happened for every project it
should not you know it should be you
know it should be a shall appointment we
think those are very uh important roles
so thank you
thank you seeing no further questions
I'll call next on Nancy martland of
good morning I'm just checking it is
still morning isn't it feels like it
could be afternoon by now
my name is Nancy martland I live in
Sugar Hill New Hampshire
and I I'm here for the little guy
I I feel here in New Hampshire local
control is something we prize unless it
seems we're talking about the sighting
of big energy projects the state already
preempts the ability of towns to decide
where these facilities may be located
imposing regulation from Concord
this does not go down well in the towns
thankfully the present SEC enabling RSA
provides for Meaningful local
participation in the state adjudicatory
process individual landowners towns
counties and other entities have the
right to participate as interveners with
legal standing
I'm going to go out on a limb here
it would help if I wore my glasses
from the standpoint of a person who was
I thought the SEC project worked just
fine
it was long it was arduous
but I didn't mind putting in the effort
and I was gratified at the thoroughness
of the procedure and I feel that the
public also
could develop trust from the obvious
thoroughness of what went on in that in
that process
the little guys right now are guaranteed
a role in a decision-making process that
goes beyond a three minute or two minute
comment in a hearing somewhere
they have the right to present testimony
Witnesses and be represented by counsel
in short it enables affected parties to
have an active role in determining their
own fate it's the New Hampshire way
with respect
I am very concerned
about the continued robustness of this
process and in particular the role of
the individual landowner or the town or
the county
because as someone has previously
mentioned we all know that the devil is
in the details and we don't know what
the rulemaking is going to look like for
example who will be allowed to intervene
who will make that decision
what will qualify someone to have that
kind of legal standing
frankly
what I see here
and particularly reinforced by what
we've witnessed in the last almost two
over two hours
is Paving the way for energy developers
to steamroll over the people of our
state with projects that are
unacceptable for a wide variety of
reasons it seems unfair
as citizens of New Hampshire we all
deserve the chance to have a hand in our
own destiny not be set aside as passive
onlookers while matters that affect us
are decided by three people in Concord
electricity is the lifeblood of our
society nobody can deny that we depend
on it in our homes our businesses our
schools our medical facilities and so
much more however while we set about
meeting our needs for electricity we
should not lose sight of other things
that are important finding a balance
should be our goal and I believe we can
find that balance we should be
thoughtful about how we meet our energy
needs in the present circumstances it
would be easy to permit any project
coming down the pike out of a rush to
increase Supply we're all feeling that
pressure
I'm sure the energy developers would
love that but every proposed project
must be carefully reviewed not just in
terms of the electricity it would Supply
but the impacts it would have on our
people their lives their livelihoods and
their communities the present SEC format
provides for a careful review that
includes the affected public in a
meaningful way and conveys fairness and
thoroughness to the General Public
hb609 I'm not sure of I don't see it
and I someone else mentioned I think
it's worthy of note that Senator Ruth
Ward the chair of the study committee
does not support this bill please itl it
thank you
thank you for driving down from Sugar
Hill please this is a pleasant drive
see no questions from the committee I'll
call next on The Honorable Suzanne Smith
who will give us the AVN perspective on
this legis proposed legislation from the
New Hampshire Audubon Society
yes good morning Mr chair and members of
the committee nice to see you all again
my name is Suzanne Smith I live in
Hebron and I am here representing New
Hampshire Audubon whose testimony was
written by Carol Foss who's the senior
advisor for Science and policy
and I want to thank you for the
opportunity to provide testimony and to
let you know New Hampshire Audubon was
one of the groups involved in the sb99
process which which was an intense study
that went on for many months to develop
a better SEC back in 2013 to better
ensure that the review of energy
facility applications serve the public
good and provide Clarity to potential
energy projects and as I say this many
people many organizations many of whom
are here today sat in on those
the specific concerns of Audubon
regarding hb609 or the loss of diverse
perspectives and expertise that the SEC
brings to citing considerations the
targeted expertise that the puc provides
did not does not necessarily address the
breadth of considerations required for
citing decisions broad expertise at the
table during deliberations ensures that
all perspectives are fairly
represented also the direct involvement
as we have heard from other groups of
natural and cultural resources
Professionals in the citing decisions is
a problem as increasing numbers of
applications for renewable energy
projects involve Greenfield sites voices
of natural resource Professionals in
particular will be critical to ensuring
the environmental impacts of energy
developments are minimized and
appropriately mitigated and we did hear
from AMC about the uh the intervening on
behalf of the bicknell's thrush which
since
representative boss said I would speak
to the avian concerns loss of public
voices from deliberations is also a
problem for Audubon citing a major
energy facilities can have broad impact
on the host and the abutting communities
providing for public testimony at
hearings and optional appointment of the
Council of the public does not
adequately replace the presence of
public perspectives during deliberations
so we strongly recommend a stakeholder
analysis of the sec's strengths and
weaknesses a consensus project that
identifies practical improvements to
address weaknesses while retaining its
strengths and we appreciate your
consideration of the testimony and urge
you to vote no or inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 609 and thank
you and I can take any questions or try
to answer them representative Harrington
has a question thank you thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question boy the Bicknell thrush that
brings back the old memories and I was
on the site evaluation committee when on
that particularly project and I'm trying
to think of and maybe you can help me
out and point something out in this bill
that would eliminate or prevent the I
think it was the Audubon Society fishing
game in the Appalachian Mountain Club
from bringing up the Bicknell thrush
issue and there was no particular
Bicknell thrust expert on the SEC eat
that time yet we managed to put in the
the what we were told was we necessary
uh requirements in the permit so that
they were protected so where in the bill
does this prevent this from happening
now by removing the the agencies like
fish and game department of natural and
cultural resources from the adjudicatory
process and leaving it all in the hands
of the puc which although they are the
best at the energy situation
um do not or do not have the expertise
to decide on the natural and cultural
see no further questions I want to thank
the honorable Suzanne Smith for being
here this morning next we'll
ask Mr Fred Ward to step forward and
give us his perspective on this
legislation
I've got a lot of things to say and I
think that I would not feel what I'm
running against a time thing and you
said 11 11 30. and I put 14 years into
this so another few days is not going to
make that much difference and I really
would prefer to have a time when I
didn't have a problem
okay
I'll put you uh in the list of people
who may not get to speak until Monday
next I'll call on Mark
I think it's McCullough from
um
you know how this discussion started and
everybody was concerned about the cost
since I've sat here and listened to this
hearing
does anybody realize does anybody agree
that CO2 emissions is the number one
issue that we have concerning
our climate this CO2 emissions from our
tailpipes CO2 emissions from all fossil
fuels that are also used to produce
power which way are you asking the
question Dave's Castle positively or
negative ice I am against this bill the
way it's written I don't know which way
are you asking you're asking but I can't
tell please uh could you gentlemen take
your debate outside if you need to do
that uh we're here this morning to
gather a testimony with regard to House
Bill 609 yes we're not here to discuss
whether CO2 is is a big issue in our
lives or not we want to know whether
hb609 is a worthwhile piece of proposed
legislation so we'd appreciate your
perspective on that but we're not
particularly interested in your
perspective on climate change there was
a lot of discussion ahead of time around
the cost of Permitting why shouldn't the
cost be based on co2 emissions per
megawatt
start from there and work your way down
down
the cost of renewable good clean energy
will be less per CO2 emissions number
one that's where that's where this game
should start we don't have a lot of time
to correct the problem of CO2 emissions
now
paramedic
I've got a little town North Stratford
they've got they had to put they've got
a a town office on one side of the road
they've got a fire department and a
a fire department an ambulance and a
maintenance building right across the
road
industry
could put that solar anywhere on their
locations
Our Town had to put their solar on the
top of this the roof of the the town
hall the town's office versus a much
better site just across the road
as a municipal
group they could not do it but as a
business
that could have been done one meter
would accredit the other through net
metering
instead the town had to pay more to site
to put this Loop put these panels in a
place where the
the costs were actually higher and and
just Why doesn't the puc
look at
smaller
power solar power production
doesn't require long transmission
you can and they talk about businesses
needing needing lower rates why can't
they why can't it be simple
to install
solar
you're pretty concerned about that clock
aren't you
well this is real
I'm one of these guys that had I saw I
saw the new
Northern Pass come through my property I
saw that about to happen 10 years
I swatched this process the damn
Northern the hydro Quebec and the whole
process they're the ones that held that
process up they're the ones that that
weren't completing their permitting
properly we were the ones that were
forcing them to fill out the permit in a
reasonable amount of time it didn't
happen I don't think the thing was done
before they completed the project
with without this the changes that were
made by in the site of iron commission
site of value evaluation committee and
their their rules that happened during
the northern process Northern Pass
project
we had to run around with freaking
stupid orange hats and stand up as a
group and fight this fight exactly what
this this committee and what you're
trying to do is a disgrace
I am ashamed
of what I have been hearing
thank goodness we got the society for
the protection of New Hampshire Force
without them this would have got Rim rug
REM rotted right down our throats
I'm sorry I took so much of your
precious
thank you we appreciate you being here
so next we'll call on Kristen Koch of
you're right I'm sorry
my mistake
next we'll call on Catherine corkery of
foreign
to take a few minutes my name is
Catherine corkery I'm from New Hampshire
Sierra Club and I appreciate
um being able to speak today
um Sierra Club opposes this bill
um for
three reasons one that has already been
highlighted was replacing the rules that
currently exist
for the site evaluation committee it's
in the rules where all the meaty juicy
stuff is and
um eliminating those
really takes away from this process
um that has
been very effective
the lengthy
in in
reviewing these
these really big projects
the other benefit of the site evaluation
committee is that it brings the project
into Focus
from all of the other agencies
you you get to really
get into the those juicy chunky parts of
a project and look at the the the
birds that are going to be affected the
wetlands that are going to be affected
and that is lost
by this bill it's lost they may not be
on the committee
but you're eliminating the rules
and I know uh representative Thomas had
a question about that
um so it's the rules that
really provide that guidance
and thirdly something that hasn't been
discussed is that
this bill as introduced puts into the
hands
not of the puc
to the responsibility of keeping our
rates low which in my opinion they are
not
and to approve new facilities
how can they hold those two things at
the same time
I think it's a conflict of interest
and I did see in the original bill it's
not addressed at all
uh and and I a quick review of the
amendment that was given though not
introduced
in the committee
I on page nine line 11 it starts
it does talk about how
um
utility rates charges and tariffs will
be considered I do not have confidence
that this puc oh oh I'm sorry page nine
of the amendment
sorry
um
page nine of the amendment on line 11.
um it does consider
rate
and I don't believe the commission can
do those two things at once they're
doing a lot of other things I'm not
saying that they can't do other things
but doing these two things
I I don't think
um I think that is a conflict of
interest and I that is my comment thank
you
thank you we appreciate your being here
representative Corman has a question for
you thank you Mr chairman if you have
you do so so I'd like you to elaborate
please a little bit more on how is it
that it's a conflict of interest for the
puc to decide on citing and keep rates
down what what what's inherent in there
that makes that a conflict of interest
undoubtedly
the cost of a facility will be passed on
and to Consumers to the ratepayers
if
they then say having that in mind say oh
well
this project
um
it's gonna affect Wetlands if we do it
this way
or if we have a study about the Beth
Nails thresh let's not have the study
let's not have the the sound tests let's
not do
all of these things that will cost money
because we have to keep rates low
all right thank you very much seeing no
further questions from the committee
well next call on Nick Paul of the of
clean energy New Hampshire to get his
perspective
thank you chairman Vos members of the
committee
uh clean energy New Hampshire is not
going to take a position on the bill
today
um Nick where
we're looking forward to reviewing the
amendment we want to remain a
constructive partner and resource to the
committee
uh as as we seek to improve our citing
process
the site evaluation committee was
established in recognition of the fact
that energy projects have statewide
impacts and should therefore be
evaluated by a Statewide body
the first project it permitted was a 112
mile long 1800 megawatt transmission
line that connects connects New England
to hydro Quebec and continues in
operation today
however the energy landscape has
transformed dramatically since this
first project was completed today
smaller more broadly distributed
generation projects are the lowest
course the lowest cost source of
electricity
and soaring electricity rates are
increasing pressure within the New
England region to develop new affordable
sources of energy Supply furthermore the
building and transportation sectors are
beginning to rapidly Electrify across
the United States which is projected to
double electricity consumption now more
than ever New Hampshire needs an
effective competent and professional
Statewide siding body capable of meeting
the needs of the interconnected State
and Regional Energy System
while minimalizing the short and
long-term impacts to New Hampshire's
high quality of life and Rich natural
resources clean energy New Hampshire
offers the following considerations for
the committee to consider in their
deliberations concerning the SEC
one the citing process should encourage
orderly and efficient rulings on energy
infrastructure cited in New Hampshire to
accomplish this a Statewide citing body
should be staffed so that it builds
institutional knowledge and expertise
regarding the sighting of energy
infrastructure this should include
dedicated professional hearings officers
who can work to Usher projects through
the process and ensure deadlines are
adhered to the New Hampshire Public
Utilities Commission is already short on
staff following the 2021 creation of the
Department of energy and is not equipped
to handle a large influx of energy
projects this will be increasingly
important as the energy transition
accelerates
which will result in more projects and
smaller projects being proposed
second the legislature should consider
increasing the size of the projects that
trigger a Statewide review energy
developers now work very hard at
partnering with towns and cities to find
proposals that can win widespread
Community buy-in as such a modest
increase of the threshold that triggers
Statewide review from 30 megawatts up to
50 megawatts may be a reasonable method
of easing The Strain on a Statewide
citing process however
such an increase should be accompanied
by a requirement that developers provide
funding for local officials to retain
expert Consultants to advise them on
Project impacts
a third any changes to the citing
process should continue to ensure that
its decisions are made in the public
interest
to accomplish this we should ensure that
public participation is enabled through
a transparent and open process the
existing decision criteria should be
retained and the role of the council for
the public should be bolstered finally
approved projects must be made in the
best interest of short and long-term
public health and Environmental Quality
while there will be unavoidable impacts
due to land use change and Landscape
modification the SEC should prioritize
preserving and improving New Hampshire's
air and water quality and the health of
the state's natural ecosystems these are
directly tied to the health of New
Hampshire residents as well as to the
strength of our economy which depends on
States our state's natural resources in
no small measure we welcome the
opportunity to consult with committee
members regarding how these elements can
be designed into the citing process
and most of you already have mine and
Sam's contact information but if you
don't it's in here so I'd be happy to
try to answer any questions that you
have
um
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I'm going to ask you
a question that I asked a previous
Witness
just in terms of the the idea that the
decision making would be put into the
puc
and understanding that you believe that
they need additional support but just
should the POC alone be the deciding
body
I don't know if I'd be comfortable
speaking directly to that but we can
have further discussions with our policy
yes representative Winnie Thomas thank
you um
I I'm just um interested I actually had
a question about whether or not you
considered the environment and that was
your final point just a question about
clean energy in general do you have an
environmental arm that looks at at the
environment for all policies or is it
just the specific one
I'm I'm sorry are you asking if clean
energy New Hampshire has an arm that
does that or if you're asking about no
I'm asking if clean energy New Hampshire
looks at the environmental impact for
for all of your policies or is it just
for this one bill that you're it's
certainly something we consider on a
all right apologies any other questions
from anybody
[Music]
that being said thank you very much
go into a recess
until Monday morning
this room is needed this afternoon and
some of us have other commitments to do
so we know the people are coming back
here on Monday and this committee will
also will be do be doing an execution as
yeah
so Mr chair there's a question about the
order of the people that will be allowed
to speak on Monday
well I can only assume it's the people
that are left in in the stack here uh
that question will have to be asked to
sure
yeah
but but bear in mind we have a lot of
bills to exec on Monday so we will have
some hard stop times as well so we will
allow plenty of time for the people that
signed up here
I will open the session for HB 142 and
present chairman Vose as a sponsor of
the bill
thank you Mr Vice chair and good morning
or
good afternoon as the case might be
to the fellow members of the committee
for the record once again I'm
representative Michael Bose
representing Rockingham District 5 the
town of Epping and I'm serving as chair
of this committee today I'm introducing
please leave this room quietly we have
another testimony going on the member
member shall proceed
we're here this uh this afternoon to
here House Bill 142 the introduction of
those of you who were here last April
will recall that
with the passage of Senate Bill 271 by
this committee
spend as much time as it took
to determine if there was any
significant
solution
to the problem of
biomass generated electricity and its
cost
I knew that a lot of other very
knowledgeable people had looked into
this question for many many years
but I needed to prove to myself that we
hadn't
accidentally overlooked
some potential solution to the high cost
of biomass generated electricity I
wanted to make sure that we turned over
every Rock
and could be therefore certain
to deal with the problem of biomass
electricity
and it's high cost
so I spent the last nine months doing
just exactly that I held over a hundred
over a dozen meetings with various
stakeholders
formal meetings and then dozens more
informal meetings and discussions with
various people
about whether or not there was anything
and those discussions led me to the
conclusion that there is no Silver
Bullet
renewable energy was determined to be a
very desirable
direction in which to move our energy
generation Supply
with the passage of purpa
we determined that generating
electricity from burning wood
was a renewable source that was worth
pursuing
purpa
enabled very generous subsidies for
biomass electricity production
but the subsidies
were necessary to continue in order for
it to continue to operate
and the subsidies became untenable
New Hampshire ratepayers paid over two
billion dollars over the course of a 20
25 30-year period
for
we've proved that biomass electricity
generated electricity is just not
efficient
so today we Face the question of what to
one of the two remaining biomass
electricity generating plants here in
New Hampshire and that's Burgess
back in 2010 Burgess signed a purchase
at the urging of members of
the administration that was in office at
because the city of Berlin and koas
county in general were suffering
suffering economically from the loss of
a major paper mill
which devastated
so negotiations began between a company
called laid law and eversource to build
on the site of the Old Paper Mill a
and the result of those negotiations was
a purchase power agreement a PPA
so-called
that allowed
the facility to be built
that purchase power agreement was to
last for 20 years and was to provide
funding for Burgess to continue
operation
in New Hampshire state law requires that
purchase power agreements have to be
approved by the Public Utilities
Commission so when the commission
investigated
the purchase power agreement that was
negotiated between Laidlaw and PSNH or
the PPA offered
a fixed price for Energy but it also
included the purchase of renewable
energy certificates from Burgess
or laid law
by PSNH
and that the purchase price of those
renewable energy credits was
considerably higher than what the RPS
Market would price those credits
certificates at
some 70 percent of the ACP price was
what was
so the Public Utilities Commission at
the time
determined that the PPA was just not
economic for the state
and so it imposed a condition on Burgess
and
pcnsa PSNH
that in order to approve the PPA
there would have to be a cap on
over-market energy costs associated with
the operation of the plant so they
determined
that a 100 million dollar cap
on EX over-market energy costs would be
an appropriate way to make the PPA
approvable
that was the condition under which they
approved it and the PPA was altered
subsequently by the parties to conform
so the plant began operating and
over-market costs began accumulating
and in 2017
the plant realized that they were going
to soon hit the 100 million dollar cap
the PPA provided that once that cap was
achieved
then the plant would have to start
paying back any excess over that 100
million dollars
in a 12-month period following the
the folks at Burgess realized they
weren't going to be able to handle that
financially so they came to the
legislature and asked for
the legislature
passed Senate bill 577.
which was amended in this committee
by our current Vice chair representative
Douglas Thomas
to provide a three-year Hiatus from the
paying back of the over 100 million
dollar excess in over-market energy
as that three-year period
was set to expire
Senate Bill SB 271 which we heard last
year
tried to address this problem
and this committee
amended that bill to extend
now that moratorium is about to expire
what has happened in the last
four or five years
our energy Market has changed somewhat
because divestiture was finally
completed the restructuring of 1996 was
finally completed
by the requirement that PSNH divest
itself of all its generation assets so
now PSNH buys its energy from the iso
New England grid from the market
no longer produces any energy itself
when PSNH and Burgess signed the
it was envisioned that the electricity
that came from Burgess would be a hedge
that bsnh would use against the price of
power that it could generate itself now
that it don't no longer generates power
that hedge is no longer
a workable
solution
so
Senate bill 577.
from 2018 I think now
was probably a mistake on the part of
this legislature
the legislature should never have gotten
involved in a private contract between
two business entities
a contract is a contract
the parties agree to it and then they
have to live by it
and if the legislature subverts the
terms of a contract
even though its intentions may have been
good
it's probably not in the long-term
interest of either the parties
that's a long-winded background way of
saying that I think it's come it's time
for this legislator to legislature to
correct its mistake the mistake it made
with the Senate bill 577.
I think it's time to roll back the clock
to 2018.
so I'm going to be proposing an
amendment and I've passed out a copy of
it to all of you it's amendment number
2023-071h
will
reset the clock to 2018 essentially
it will wipe out
any accumulated over-market energy costs
that have accrued since 2018 and forgive
them
Burgess will not be required to to pay
those
over Market costs back
it's a fairly significant amount of
money somewhere around 48 million
dollars
but I think since the legislature
created
that 488 million dollar
obligation
since it's already been recovered
through stranded cost recovery
rates by the utility
the legislature can forgive that debt
so that's what I propose to do in this
amendment
by resetting the clock I mean that with
that debt gone
now
any further over-market energy costs
that accumulate
above the 100 million that's already
established by the p in the PPA will
have to be paid back according to the
and if that
doesn't work
for either PCN PSNH or for Burgess
then the two of them need to get
together and figure out how to make it
work it's not up to the legislature to
make that work
it's up to the companies who the parties
who are the parties of a private
contract
so that's why I've proposed this
amendment That Forgives the the debt
and then holds the parties to the terms
of the contract
I think it's in the best interest
interest of the economics of the State
of New Hampshire
that we step aside and step out of the
way and let this process between these
I've submitted written testimony and in
my written testimony I talk a little bit
about
the
docket
the proceeding at the Public Utilities
Commission to approve the PPA way back
in 2010 some of the testimony from that
docket I also talk about
some of the concerns that people may
have that if we pass this legislation
Burgess may decide to close and jobs
will be lost
but I would remind people that
when you subsidize jobs in a protected
industry
it can be very expensive
the Peterson Institute for example
speculates that it cost two hundred
fifty thousand dollars annually for each
it's never fun it's never
easy
to say that jobs may be lost but if
that's what happens that's what happens
I'm hoping that won't happen
I'm hoping that with a relatively High
Cost of energy today electricity today
that Burgess will be able to continue to
function
under the terms of the PPA
or if they can't that they will get
together with PSNH or eversource and try
to work out an arrangement that will
work
and that the PPA or that the Public
Utilities Commission can approve because
any alteration of the existing PPA would
so that is going to conclude my
testimony I'll take questions of course
and then there are other people who will
want to speak on this issue as well I'm
sure
representative Winnie Thompson's Thomas
oh
New York
um I
thank you for your testimony and I have
two clarification questions one is in
the original Bill not the amendment on
lines 16 and 17 it says um
all relief provided to the plant shall
be deemed to be reasonable legitimate
and in the public interest how will
those be determined and or measured
those are well-defined terms by the
Public Utilities Commission
and in this legislation it it just says
that the legislature is saying that the
terms
are judged to be just and reasonable so
there's illegal Amendment legislation
Amendment Amendment text has the same
um all right and my second question is
um you you talked about the 48 million
that would be um forgiven would that
it will not because the funds have
already been recovered by the utility
and its stranded cost recovery charge
representative Harrington thank you um
thank you for taking my question so just
to make this clear what we're basically
saying is that the contract as it was
originally agreed to and actually
dramatically pursued by the biomass
facility they wanted this contract
really really bad and it went to the puc
the puc originally rejected it because
they didn't like some of the stuff in it
it was then
renegotiated between the two parties and
approved by the puc that was in effect
and it remains in effect now but what
you're saying is the amount of
over-market rates that have been being
paid by the rate payers from 2018 until
the enactment of this bill if it passes
is going to be forgiven that's the
amount of 48 million dollars so the rate
payers would have eventually handed
Burgess biomass of 48 million dollar
check
no I'm not saying that because the money
has already been the 48 million has
already been recovered by the utility
and its stranded cost recovery charge so
all of us rate payers have already paid
it follow-up
well we wouldn't have paid it if we
hadn't given this bill passed in other
words the only reason that it's the rate
pay is paid that bill is because of the
of the laws that would change eventually
all the money would have had been paid
back by Burgess in according with the
contract so in effect the rate pay is a
giving even though they've already paid
it through the stranded cost they have
and will can give Burgess about 48
million dollars that was not in
compliance with the contracted Burgess
negotiated
yes that is correct but what I'm saying
is that that 48 million
wouldn't have accrued had this
legislature not stepped in with Senate
Bill 577 and it created a uh a pause if
you will a suspension of uh the terms of
the PPA follow up and let's be the last
one
well when you say it wouldn't be accrued
by because Burgess would have gone out
of business or they would have paid the
money back no because the terms of the
PPA say that once the hundred million
dollar level is reached any further over
Market charges have to be paid back
within the next 12 months so on a year
by year basis
Burgess would either have had to pay
those over Market charges back
or they would have violated the terms of
the PPA
and because the PPA went into effect in
19 or so
approximately 48 million has accumulated
okay okay seeing another question from
representative Corman
three times in a row I got that right
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question I'm sorry but I'm
still a bit confused about this 48
million
it's money that has already been charged
to the rate payer as you said so what
we're free what are we forgiving is
there money that is there 48 million
that is coming from somewhere not coming
from somewhere going somewhere not going
somewhere and I'm talking about going
forward not in the past okay good
question my apologies for not explaining
it thoroughly to begin with
so the way the PPA works is that
a fund was uh
the PPA was was created with something
called a cumulative reduction Factor
the cumulative reduction Factor
was a accounting way of accounting for
and
the CRF
as it was called was set up
within at the recommendation of the PPA
to be capped at 100 million dollars
once it reached 100 million dollars then
the terms of the PPA were that the any
excess funds over that hundred million
would be returned to to uh rate payers
that provision of the PPA therefore the
fund began to accumulate
Monies that were not paid back in a
12-month period
and at the end of the three years
well now almost four years
suspension of that CRF the funds that
have accumulated are roughly 48 million
does that explain it
okay
representative Christian
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
um so my understanding based on some
Communications I've received is that
currently
um Burgess is only receiving eight cents
a kilowatt hour for their energy under
the current agreement versus like the
default rate is 22 will that be
brought back into balance going forward
or does this not impact that at all
now this legislation does not
in any way change the PPA that's that
can only be done by the parties that are
um
part of the PPA who the two parties that
negotiated the PPA and any changes they
make to it will have to be approved by
see any other questions thank you so
much uh chairman Rose for your testimony
I will call next Mr Tom Franz from the
Department of energy
good evening well it almost feels like
thank you for the opportunity to testify
on hb142 a bill relative to the
operation of the Burgess biopower plant
I am Tom Frantz director of the
regulatory support division of the New
Hampshire Department of energy
the New Hampshire Department of energy
opposes HB 142 and my comments this
morning this afternoon addressed the
original Bill and not not the amendment
which we haven't reviewed yet and we'd
be happy to take a look at
um
HP 142 would protect the continued
operation the birds biopower plant
that's clearly stated in the proposed
original HB 142 Bill and how does it do
that by removing the protection of
forwarded rate payers in the puc's order
approving the PPA back in 2011.
chairman Vose gave a very thorough and
accurate description of the history of
this so I'm not going to spend a lot of
time on that although I had comments on
it earlier but he addressed it the
history of the uh PPA rather rather
clearly and well
that protection as he mentioned did cap
over Market costs at a hundred million
dollars
through through that cumulative
reduction Factor
and of course that has been an issue at
the original order proving this PPA
clearly stated that the the cumulative
reduction Factor was intended and I
quote to mitigate risk to customers
end quote
this bill as originally proposed HP 142
would direct the PC to amend any of its
orders is necessary to protect the
continued operation of the plant no
matter what those costs are
so the original order
trying to balance rate payers interests
with those of the owner of the plant and
and the benefits that accrue to the
facility clearly would be taken out of
that equation
so the cumulative reduction Factor
in 145 to 48 million dollar range uh
under this bill would remain and
potentially increase
so that balance those costs those risks
to customers would continue under the
hb-142 as proposed
this is an example what New Hampshire's
10-year energy strategy States would
should be avoided expensive targeted
payments to specific
favored
non-technologically neutral plants at
high cost and at risk the rate payers
so for those reasons the New Hampshire
thank you Mr Franz for being here this
morning representative Harrington has a
question for you
thank you Trina and thank you for taking
my question it seems to be the issue
here is where is the money going to come
from if they have to continue to pay
this this back now in your experience in
the electric markets in New England have
there been previous plants where they
simply weren't found economical and did
they close or were they just we sold
into the market at a lower price
well over the long term you have to at
least cover uh all your costs to stay
economically viable in the short term if
you're covering at least all your
variable costs you could run for a while
hoping that market conditions will
change or costs underlying the facility
will be lower and net over the long term
you can cover your variable costs and
fixed costs but the short answer to that
question is some plants close we've seen
that across New England that they've
assessed the market their own cost
structure and determine that the costs
exceed the revenues they're receiving or
will receive over the over the long term
and they've closed
other plants will
stay in operation for a while hoping
that either prices go up or costs go
down or both and that they'll uh be
profitable over the long term I think it
varies somewhat based on the plant the
fuel
even where they're located
follow-up
follow up yeah and would a third option
be that some plants that couldn't
operate under the present price
structure because what they owed what
their contracts were would simply sell
their plant to somebody else maybe at a
reduced cost and that new buyer then
could operate with the lower Capital
cost involved and may operate as well
that's definitely an option also and
that has also occurred all those in a
very large involved complex market like
uh we have in ice and New England have
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh so I'm curious
about these plants that have closed have
what sorts of fuel sources have they
used I mean have there been biomass
plants that are closed oh yes natural
gas oil I mean what's what's closed uh
basically all of the above
uh oil plants have closed uh essentially
they don't run very often anyway they
have what we have we call a low capacity
factors
PSNH owned one it's still running uh the
capacity factor in that plant the last I
saw was under one percent
uh it basically is what we call a
capacity Revenue plan that it gets
revenue from the iso New England forward
capacity market and and really doesn't
depend at all on Energy prices for its
Revenue stream it because of oil is a
high priced uh fuel on the margin for
the most part in New England and it's
there to run when ISO really needs to
keep the grid up uh and so those plants
are Bid in to the forward capacity
market and if they clear they get the
forward capacity Market costs I mean
revenue stream and they may run very
very little but when they are asked to
run they better run or there's a penalty
provision so those many oil plants
closed especially in the early to mid
2000 Range
the biomass facilities that were under
qualifying facility purpose rates as
representative Bose mentioned when those
20-year read orders ended many of them
stayed open for a while but most of
those are now closed and and we had
that one time I think uh eight or nine
biomass qfs
so only a couple of those are are still
operational
and usually when the prices are fairly
high in ice and New England Market
coal plants have all but disappeared
from the region except for Merrimack the
last operating coal plant in the region
and we even had nuclear power plants
close in the in the late 90s mid to late
90s
okay I'd remind everybody that we have
six cards left here we have a hard stop
at one o'clock
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair
um
can you tell me what is causing this
biomass plant to run so inefficient and
inefficiently is it leadership is it
prices well
I wouldn't say it uh
I we we did an audit at the department
of energy on the plant and and
there was nothing there that would
state that this is a poorly run plant we
think the Management's well done the
employees are top-notch the facilities
really for biomass facilities as as and
I visited lots of biomass Phillies as as
fine of biomass facilities you'll
probably find
it's an inefficient way to make
electricity As You Are basically burning
wood chips with high moisture contents
uh just spin it spin a turban
and and those heat rates
if the fuel is cheap enough
you can you can do it fairly cheaply but
uh wood is not a very cheap commodity
and the efficiency of even a fine
facility
has a high heat rate content so it takes
a lot of heat to actually produce one
kilowatt hour of electricity follow-up
um so given that it appears to be the
type of energy that it's that it's using
how can we ensure that giving this
subsidy will result in them running any
more efficiently in the future and and
not just getting back to this point
again at some at some time
I don't think there's any guarantee of
that there's no guarantee I don't I I
think in today's high gas price Market
we see plants that could run
in the market more than we've seen when
gas prices are low when natural gas
prices are low this this plant will
without a doubt uh be above Market thank
you
representative Noel has a question thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question uh with your perspective on the
on the plant here uh the price that they
negotiated in the PPA originally was
that a reasonable price or did it
reflect their their costs more than uh
Public Services costs
uh that's a
that's a multi-multi-million dollar
question
[Laughter]
and it was a complex PPA uh 20 years had
three basic revenue streams associated
with it energy which underlying the
energy was the fuel price for wood
and the efficiency of converting wood
chips into electricity
that was
Changed by the puc essentially in its uh
analysis in order
then the capacity revenues which were
based on forecasts also and direct
prices those are the three major revenue
streams and so over a 20-year period
some periods are going to look good some
periods are going to look bad and uh the
low but I think a lot of people missed
at the time was that tremendously
tremendous technological developments in
lowering natural gas prices and and the
prices in the 2008 nine time frame 2010
even for natural gas we were in the five
six dollars per mmbtu and as you know
natural gas prices
uh for most of the 2000 teens were down
in the
1.85 to two dollars and fifty cents per
mmbtu and since gas is on the margin in
ISO New England many many many many
hours a high proportion of the hours
setting the price that that
dramatically and adversely affected uh
um
and I just realized I forgot to turn on
my mic
thank you Mr chairman I appreciate the
opportunity to be here today and to
speak on behalf of Burgess biopower
I will give you just a very brief
overview of the facility itself before I
dive into some of the more relevant
issues as they are associated with this
with this bill there's also some
additional information that I provided
in these handouts that I won't touch on
for the sake of of being respectful of
everyone's time
uh Burgess biopower is a 75 megawatt
biomass power plant that is located at
the site of the former Fraser Mill paper
mill in Berlin New Hampshire it's the
fourth largest generator in New
Hampshire and it is the state's largest
renewable generator
we provide reliable base load power that
runs on local fuel instead of out of
state natural gas or other fossil fuels
we are the largest single buyer of
biomass in the state purchasing about
800 000 tons of low-grade wood each year
from 154 different New Hampshire towns
and all 10 counties you'll hear a little
bit more about that from some friends
that will speak behind us and we make
some significant contributions to New
Hampshire's economy we support 240 jobs
we provide nearly 70 million dollars in
economic activity each year
which equates to nearly 1.4 billion
dollars over the 20-year life of the PPA
you'll hear from mayor Grenier about our
contributions to the city of Berlin but
generally we support critical energy
Independence and fuel diversity
especially amid the major changes and
disruptions in energy markets that we
have seen in recent years and our
contract price is stable over time
so the facility was developed for really
for three reasons and representative
Vose did a great job of of giving some
of the history there but the first was
environmental which was to bring a
large-scale renewable generation asset
to New Hampshire in order to satisfy
some of the RPS requirements the second
was economics it was to act as an
economic anchor in the city of Berlin
and the North Country which had been
really devastated financially when the
Fraser paper mill closed
and the third was for energy purposes to
be a to be a price stable hedge in the
fluctuating energy markets so we have
delivered on all of those objectives
but the Clause that that representative
Vose mentioned that is in our PPA called
the cumulative reduction factor or CRF
puts the facility at Future risk I think
it's important to note that it is a book
entry it is not an actual bank account
and what that Clause does is it Compares
burgess's long-term fixed price of
energy against that fluctuating day
ahead market price and it tracks the
difference between those two
as representative Vose mentioned there
is a cap on the CRF of 100 million
dollars which has been reached the
current balance is roughly 148 150
million which is roughly equivalent to
two years worth of the economic activity
that we generate
but I think it's important to consider
whether the calculation of the CRF is an
accurate and accurate reflection of the
actual cost to rate payers
it Compares our stable energy price
against a market price which individual
consumers do not actually pay
so I think a more accurate estimate of
the actual consumer cost of energy is to
look at the energy component of default
service
and so for example if the CRF had been
calculated by comparing our energy cost
to that energy component of default
service since 2018 when competitive
bidding started
it would have peaked at 44 million
dollars in October of 2021 it would have
steadily declined since then and it
would have hit zero in early 2023.
but aside from the CRF calculation which
is again an accounting mechanism the
actual dollar value impact to ratepayers
is really based on how our power is used
so before divestiture it was
incorporated into the default service
mix and it served as a as a load reducer
but when divestiture occurred the puc
directed eversource to to continue to
purchase power from us but then to sell
our power into the market
so now eversource purchase art purchases
our power according to the contract at
that steady PPA price they resell it
into the day ahead market and any cost
difference between those two things is
recovered from ratepayers
we don't have any control over how our
power is used once it has been purchased
from us
but the thing that makes it even more
challenging is that the existing CRF
calculation that compares our price
against the day ahead Market
would remain the same even if our power
was transacted at a higher value so for
example right now our cost of energy is
substantially less than default Service
pricing
if it was possible to use our power as
part of the default service mix and sell
it instead of selling it at a loss into
the day ahead market then that would
have significant rate payer benefits but
even so the CRF would still track the
difference the same way against the day
ahead Market which continues to put us
at risk so it makes us responsible for
repaying a debt that was never actually
incurred and it puts the plant's
operation in Jeopardy for no really for
no reason
so we are asking for your help to
resolve the CRF issue in order to
provide long-term certainty for the for
the plant
um the lifespan of the facility extends
well beyond the PPA term
um and what's especially important to us
in terms of providing certainty is it
gives us the opportunity to pursue some
co-location Partners so the the site the
the facility sits on 60 Acres we have
sought these opportunities to further
develop the site
um and and we have struggled to find
Partners to do so because as soon as
they realize that there is some sort of
mechanism that provides uncertainty as
to whether or not we are going to
continue to operate they are not willing
to invest in in locating alongside us
um for example we have recently been
approached by a company who is
interested in in pursuing a biochar
facility alongside our operation and I
think one thing that is particularly
exciting about that is it gives us the
opportunity to really use some symbiotic
shared infrastructure so some of the
good handling infrastructure those kinds
of things it would also be a company
that could bring an additional 300 000
tons of capacity to the low-grade wood
Market at a time when that industry is
is struggling
um but but like any of the others this
type of project will not move forward
unless we have some certainty around our
future operations
so I will stop there
um I appreciate that these are
complicated issues uh I appreciate your
willingness to dig into them we believe
that Burgess is an important resource
and that it should be protected as part
of New Hampshire's energy generation mix
and we are asking for your help in doing
that so with that said I will stop
talking and I will take questions
thank you excuse me thank you we
appreciate you being here and giving us
your perspective
we have questions from the members of
the committee for Ms Boone
representative Harrington
thank you thank you you've taken my
question you know we've heard all this
stuff about how it helps out this and
helps out that but the fact it remains
that Burgess actively pursued a contract
with Public Service as a condition for
building their plan without that PPA you
would have never gotten financing and
now I haven't heard you present any
alternative than what you just want to
not have to pay the money back that you
will to a contract you agreed to would
you want us to sign a bill that says the
contract's invalid and we'll continue to
subsidize Burgess I haven't heard you
come up with anything other than please
help but you did willingly sign a
contract and the bottom line is you
don't want to live up to the terms of
I think it's important to note that the
PPA was signed and and negotiated at a
time when eversource was still
generating its own power and when
divestiture occurred it changed the
terms of the contract itself and of uh
the nature by which the the market is
working and we are asking for your help
in helping us to navigate that change in
terms
quick follow-up
follow-up yeah when you say asking for
help what's your proposal what is it
well
we had been discussing an amendment to
this bill that is not being presented
today and that Amendment did lay out
some things that we had requested for
support
we certainly support the
um the amendment that representative
Vose has brought forth in forgiving the
accrual uh the accrued amount resulting
further questions from the committee
representative Corman has one thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question going forward is there a path
for this plant to actually be cost
effective
I think if you look at the cost as they
are currently our plant is quite cost
effective we are significantly less than
default Service pricing right now but I
think the the biggest challenge that we
face is as I said we don't have any
control over our power once it is
purchased from us but we are responsible
essentially for the difference in
seeing none thank you Ms Boone for being
here
I'd like to call next on Paul Grenier
the mayor of Berlin to get his comments
and perspective on this issue I'll
remind everyone that we're going to have
a hard stop at one o'clock
so that gives us about 13 minutes uh
more then we'll have to recess this
hearing until Monday
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Paul Grenier and I
serve as the mayor of the city of Berlin
I began my first term in January 2010
largely because of my support for the
Burgess biomass project in 2006 Frazier
Paper Company shuttered the pulp Mill
located in the middle of Berlin
eliminating over 375
manufacturing and maintenance jobs and
sending an economic shock to our city
that no one could truly prepare for
unemployment in the Berlin area was over
10 percent
hard-working bright young families were
leaving in a tax base the pulp Mill
represented evaporated overnight
to make an already difficult situation
even more dire
Decades of Legacy environmental
degradation made on 120 Acre Site in the
center of our city made a virtually
impossible to redevelop
faced with such a massive headwind many
folks just plainly gave up
while the site was being dismantled for
scrap a handful of citizens began
conversations with then New Hampshire
State dread commissioner George bald on
how to best utilize the site
the previous pulp Mill owner installed a
new black liquor boiler in 1994 and was
at the time state of the art that boiler
was the centerpiece of the Burgess
biopower plant Redevelopment project and
after almost three years of working
through tough financing and state
permitting issues construction began in
2011.
at that time Burgess biopower was the
only entity to show even the slightest
of interest in setting up shop in Berlin
Burgess made Believers out of our
community the remaining folks who hadn't
left had a skip in their step that
wasn't witness for some time and most of
all a sense of community Pride once
again took hold
Burgess biopower isn't the end-all and
be-all for us but it was the Catalyst
the first to kick in the door to
reinvent Berlin
although Berlin's Collective efforts at
diversifying our economy is beginning to
take shape it is a slow and tedious
process Outdoor Motor outdoor motorized
Recreation and Corrections industry
aside
Burgess biopower Remains the straw that
stirs Berlin's drink it is our largest
property taxpayer as well as our largest
water and sewer user customer they
generate millions of dollars in the
purchase of goods and services in Berlin
and kohas County
also with Burgess using just a portion
of their site there is room and
available energy to attract new business
to Berlin
Berlin psychologically and financially
can illiford to lose burgers we've had a
serious brain drain from 2006 to 2010.
we just don't have the human capital to
survive another Exodus
by all measures Burgess solidified our
existence just when it was needed the
most
we are slowly making strides to expand
our economy and Burgess will play a huge
pipe in Berlin's future
I ask all of you to vote ought to pass
on House Bill 142 and let's keep Burgess
part of New Hampshire's Energy Mix but
just as importantly the backbone of the
new North Country economy
be willing to take any questions thank
you Mr Mayor I appreciate you making the
long drive down here
and I wanted to get your testimony in
before we ended today so that you
wouldn't have to drive down again on
Monday
thank you questions for uh the mayor
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you very much Mr chair
um is the the um
the city of Berlin uh interested in
doing any kind of oversight on on this
biomass plant
well we actually the
I don't know what type of oversight we
would you would be looking at for us to
keep an eye on a private business
I can tell you from not only an elected
servant of the community but as a
citizen Burgess biopower their senior
management team and their employees and
Company
have been nothing but awesome
uh Community Partners
they it's they're a huge addition to the
community they are great corporate
citizens
every Community should be blessed with
having us a a corporate partner of this
magnitude in their community and
remember they're redeveloping
the center of commute of the city
which has for over a hundred years been
part of the pulp and paper making
process including I might add a
five-acre uh parcel right in the middle
of that site that's a Mercury
contamination site
follow up follow up no I I understand
they're they're awesome I can probably
agree with you on that but will the city
be involved in any kind of oversight to
make sure they don't sort of get into
the same rut that they that are the same
problem that they're in right now well
what I what we are investigating is uh
communities
uh aggregating to purchase power
and when I see myself I'm a default
customer of eversource just so I can
gauge and watch
how I'm paying 22 cents for power
there may be a pretty significant
opportunity for us
to purchase power in a different way
which would increase burgess's synergy
thank you I think I think burgess's
opportunities are Limitless
if you can unshackle the fact that
they're paying they're getting paid
eight cents in the marketplace when the
marketplace is generating 22 cents and
eversource tells the puc in the public
that at 22 cents it's a pass-through
I'm not the smartest guy in the world
but I I do the math and from eight cents
that they're paying uh Burgess and 22
cents that they're collecting from the
rate payers there seems to be an
opportunity in my mind where we can come
I would just like to Echo the
the staff at Burgess biopower I've had a
opportunity to work with the staff there
this particularly the senior senior
staff over the last nine months and I
find them to be of the
the top-notch quality in terms of of the
staff of of the plant and uh it's been a
pleasure to work with them
and uh I'll look forward to working with
them again in the future I hope
so thank you mayor Mr chairman as as an
aside I want to thank you for your
Amendment proposal it goes a long way
we're going to figure this thing out
I hope we do I hope we do
all right thank you very much thank you
no further questions uh I'm going to
we only have four more people who want
to testify on their all local to Concord
so nobody will be forced to drive from
Berlin to uh to testify
on Monday morning we will resume
we will recess 142 until Monday morning
at the conclusion of the resumed public
then we will resume this public hearing
then when this public hearing is
finished then we will open executive
sessions as scheduled currently in the
calendar for a variety of house bills
including these two house bills we have
to finish them by Thursday
uh because we have a hard stop in the
house calendar to get these bills out
the door by March 16th
so Monday will be our last chance and
that's when we will finish all these
bills
so we have to vacate the room there are
other people coming in at one o'clock so
I appreciate everybody being here and
thank you for your participation we'll
foreign
you see
peppers
foreign